ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY THAT TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HERE
HERE IN THE CAP. WITH SOME OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS PART TO.
REMOTE ARE MEMBER ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY AS SENATOR STERN.
FINISHED PLEASE INTRODUCE YOUR
STAFF PERSON IN THE INTRODUCED
YOURSELF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ABSENT HENRY STERN HERE
IN THE MY SENATE DISTRICT
OFFICE WITH- MY DISTRICT CHIEF
JERRY WHAT. VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATORS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MOVEMENT YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK THE POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. ONLY USE THE
ABOVE TWO PARAGRAPHS ONLY IF
YOU HAVE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT. THAT STILL
SOCIAL DISTANCE TO REQUIREMENTS
HELLO. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN ND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE SIX ONE.
ZERO SEVEN FOUR ZERO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECOM CONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS. PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND FOR THE SENATE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
WHO. TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ONE FOR
SUPPORT. ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO SIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER ONCE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOR SUPPORT.
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. THIS CAN
BE A SHORT WAIT SO WE ASK YOU
TO STAY ON THE LINE ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER. YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT THANK YOU AND-
AND OR I WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE SO ONCE
AGAIN. YOU WILL BE ASSIGNED. A
NUMBER. AND THAT NUMBER WILL BE
CALLED WHEN THAT NUMBER IS
CALLED YOU WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK PLEASE
NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
BANJA DEVISED THE DEVICE YOU
ARE WATCHING. SO IN ORDER TO
ONCE AGAIN. ORDER TO AVOID A
QUICKLY STICK FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND THAT WE AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WANT TO CORRECT MYSELF AND IF
YOU WERE THIS IS- CONCERNING. A
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO SO YOU'RE
ASKING TO DIAL TEN. ONE IN ZERO
TEN. A AND THAT WILL OF. GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS
YOUR POSITION IN SUPPORT- IN
OPPOSITION THEN YOU WILL BE
ASSIGNED A NUMBER AND THEN THE
MODERATOR WILL CALL YOU WHEN
IT'S TIME FOR SPEAK. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY. YOU MUST MEET
TO YOUR DEVICE AND I HAD
MENTIONED THAT ALREADY AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. THAT YOU MEET
YOUR DEVICE. AND WHEN YOU'RE
ASKED TO SPEAK THAT YOU ON
MUTE. YOUR DEVICE TO SPEAK. I
WILL MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS HIS CUSTOMER.
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS GEORGE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT
SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. WE HAVE. A WE HAD A
SIX COMMITTEE BILLS ON TODAY'S
A GENDER. AGENDA HOWEVER AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE COMMITTEE. WE
WILL ONLY HERE FIVE BILLS TODAY.
BEFORE WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION
ON THE BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM COMMITTEE- CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CHAIR WESSEL
PRESIDENT- WESSEL PRESENCE BY
STERN MORLOCK. VICE CHAIR MORE
LIKE PRESENTS. SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHIANG. CHIANG
HERE. DOLLY. EARLIER SENATOR W.
MICROPHONE HERE CENTER DOLLY
HERE. DOT. THE HE DID IT AGAIN.
ON MICROPHONE NOT ON. BELMONT
HERE. DOT HERE THANK YOU
SENATOR. HERTZBERG. HELLO HERE
HALE HERE. MCGUIRE RUBIO. RUBIO
PRESIDENT RUBIO HERE. SKINNER
HERE INNER HERE. STERN. START
HERE. STERN HERE. WIENER
PRESIDENT. WIENER HERE. JERRY
HAVE CORN THE CONSULTANT NOTES
ACCORD HAVE CORMAN'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST AUTHOR. WE HAVE THE
FIRST BILL IN THE QUEUE TODAY
IS AB FIVE SEVEN SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOW ARE
YOU I'M GREAT NHI<c.cyan> I'M DOING</c>
FANTASTIC THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ODAY THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED TO WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON STURGEON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SPECIAL THINGS FOR
THE INCREDIBLE WORK YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF DID TO HELP US
WITH THE BILL AND THE
AMENDMENTS. I WILL TAKE ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS. AB FIVE
SEVENTY OFFERS A CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN RURAL AND
URBAN CALIFORNIA. BY REFORMING
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND PROGRAM. AND
EXTENDING AND ADJUSTING AN
EXISTING FUNDING STREAM. AS
WE'VE ALL OF UNFORTUNATELY SEEN
THE ON GOING PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS HAS MADE IT PAINFULLY
CLEAR TO THE OUTSIDE WORLD THE
WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE KNOWN FOR
YEARS. OUR WORK TO DIGITALLY
CONNECT ALL CALIFORNIANS IS
VIRTUALLY IMPORTANT NOW MORE
THAN EVER. AB FIVE SEVENTY
PRIORITIZE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE.
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED. RURAL
AND URBAN AREAS WELL OPENING
THE DOOR FOR A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TRIED TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
CONNECTIVITY IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. MY PROPOSAL OFFERS
A RESPONSIBLE PATHWAY TO
RELIABLE FUTURE PROOF BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY FOR THE ONE IN
EIGHT CALIFORNIA HOME TO STILL
DO NOT HAVE INTERNET ACCESS AND
THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
FACE EVEN HIGHER NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES REMAIN
DISCONNECTED. AB FIVE SEVENTY
REJECTS THE STATUS QUO THAT IS
A FAR TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THE BOTH RURAL
AND URBAN PARTS OF OUR STATE
WITHOUT INTERNET ACCESS.
NECESSARY TO CONNECT TO GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT. ONE IS THE
LIFESAVING TECHNOLOGY FOR
TELEMEDICINE DEMOCRATIZE THE
DISTANCE LEARNING. ENABLE
PRECISION AGRICULTURE AND
SUSTAIN SMALL BUSINESSES OVER
HALF OF WHOM WORK FROM HOME. MY
BILL ENSURES GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ARE
AWARDED TO APPLICANTS WHO ARE
WILLING AND ABLE TO QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY CONNECT HOUSEHOLDS.
COMMUNITY ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS
SMALL BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYERS
BY BUILDING FIBER MIDDLE MILE
THAT WILL PROVIDE HIGHER SPEEDS
AND ACCESS TO CONNECTIVITY TO
ALL THOSE WHO ARE UNSERVED
ALONG THE PATHWAY OF DEPLOYMENT.
WITH THE REQUIREMENT OF FIBER
MIDDLE MILE THOSE PROJECTS WILL
PROVIDE TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
ADAPT TO HIGHER SPEEDS BEYOND
THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS OF
TWENTY FIVE THREE IN AB FIVE
SEVENTY AND EVOLVING TECHNOLOGY.
DO NOT SENATORS ALLOW OTHERS TO
MISCAST THE ISSUE OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED HOUSEHOLDS WITH THE
GOAL FOR TECHNOLOGY WE WANT
PROJECTS TO PROVIDE IN THE
PROGRAM. BY AMENDING THE DE OF
UNSERVED TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE WE HAVE MADE MORE THAN
HALF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM.
WITHOUT EXTENDING FUNDING. LET
ME SAY THAT AGAIN WITHOUT
EXTENDING FUNDINGTO MATCH A
PORTION OF THAT NEED WITH THE
AMENDMENTS I ACCEPT TODAY.
NEITHER URBAN OR RURAL
CONSTITUENTS FORGET WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE APPROVED EARLIER THIS
YEAR. AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
WILL BE LAST. AB FIVE SEVENTY
HOLDS INCUMBENT PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE BY ALLOWING THE
CPUC TOWARD GRANTS TO THOSE ARE
WHO ARE WILLING AND ALE TO
BUILD OUT BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE OR EXISTING
PROVIDERS HAVE FAILED TO DO SO.
RELIABLE INTERNET CONNECTIVITY
WILL REMAIN AN OVER DO
NECESSITY LONG AFTERTHIS
PANDEMIC HAS SUBSIDED AND THIS
PIVOTAL MOMENT IN OUR GLOBAL
HISTORY OFFERS US A TRUE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD BY
INVESTING IN THE FUTURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND CHOOSING TO
PRIORITIZE OF THOSE WE HAVE
BEEN LEFT IN THE DARK. WE WILL
NOT LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND IN
CALIFORNIA MUST EMBRACE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDS IN COORDINATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND. DOLLARS BY INVESTING IN
OPEN ACCESS FIBER MIDDLE MILE
CONNECTIVITY FOR ALL. OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
OFFERING SB ELEVEN THIRTY. A
PROPOSAL THAT OFFERS NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WHILE
INCREASING ELIGIBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND GRANTS. WITHOUT A
COMPLIMENTARY EFFORT TO ADOPT A
FUNDING COMPONENT THE
LEGITIMATE INTERESTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUE RAISES FOR INCREASED
SPEEDS ENSURING URBAN
CONNECTIVITY DOES THERE'S OFFER
EMPTY ELIGIBILITY. I HAVE
OFFERED COLLABORATION A MEETING
EACH OF OUR GOALS AND I BELIEVE
WE ARE BOTH IN BOTH COMMITTED
TO COLLABORATING TO REACH OUR
MUTUAL GOAL. SB FIVE SEVENTY IS
ESSENTIAL TO OUR STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND PROVIDES
A MEASURED AND MEANINGFUL
PATHWAY TO ACHIEVE A BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT. WE CAN
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
BETWEEN THOSE WITH INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY AND THOSE WHO
DEPEND ON FAST AND RELIABLE
INTERNET ACCESS AS A NORMAL
PART OF THE DAILY LIVES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS TRISH KELLY ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY VISION AND EDUARDO
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TECHNOLOGY FUND
THANK YOU. VERY WELL. DO WE
HAVE THE SPEAKERS CUED SO MARK.
KELLY VALLEY VISION. THIS IS
TRISH KELLY FROM VALLEY MISSION
YES WELCOME MISS KELLY. DO YOU
WANT TO TESTIFY. YEAH THANK YOU
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO. AB FIVE
SEVENTY AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
BEEN A GREAT LEADER FOR US HERE
IN THE REGION AND STATE WIDE ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUE OF BROADBAND
ACCORDION CONNECTIVITY. I'M THE
MANAGING DIRECTOR ABOUT THE
VISION WERE OF REGIONAL
NONPROFIT. SERVING PRIMARILY
DID SACRAMENTO CAPITAL REGION
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITY
WE ALSO SERVE AS THE MANAGER OF
THE BEAUTY FUNDED CONNECTED
AREA CONNECTED CAPITAL AREA
BROADBAND CONSORTIUM WE
RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CONNECTING OUR UNDERSERVED IN
AND UNSERVED HELPFUL TO MAKE A
98% CALL ACROSS THE STATE FOR
EACH REGION. AND ALONG WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE REGION. WE
MANAGE WORK FOURTEEN EDUCATION
INITIATIVES INCLUDING FOR
DIGITAL SKILLS THAT ARE NEEDED
ACROSS ALL INDUSTRIES AND OUR
REGION'S ECONOMIC STRATEGY
WHICH HAS BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AS THE MAJOR
PRIORITY YEAH AND ALSO TO
SUPPORT OUR TO CONNECT ECONOMY.
SO AS A FAMILY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY LAID OUT THERE ARE
MANY MANY- ON MATT NEED. ACROSS
THE STATE AND CALLED IT AS
LAID BARE THESE PERSISTENT
STRUCTURAL DISPARITIES WHICH
ARE MANIFEST IN OUR REGION FOR
HELPFUL. INSTITUTIONS AND
BUSINESSES SO WE SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE SEVENTY BECAUSE THAT WILL
PROVIDE POSITIVE. IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND PROGRAMS
INCLUDING FOR CRITICAL MIDDLE
MY OUTSIDE THE PROJECT.
CONNECTING ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS
FAIRGROUND TRIBAL. LAND THE
FEDERAL. WHICH IS ALSO CREE FOR
HELPING OUT DRESSER EMERGENCY
SERVICE THE- SAYING IN EMERGE
SUCH AS OUR AGAIN FIRE. IT
WOULD ALSO ALLOW IT TO UPGRADE
TO LOW INCOME UNDER THIRD
COMMUNITY WE WITH THE- FELL AND
THOUSANDS WHICH TO THE STATE OF
THEN WHAT BEHIND AND THAT
HAPPENED TO A GREAT DEGREE ARE
WE IS WELL. AND THEN TO PROVIDE
THE CRITICALLY NEEDED FUNDING
FOR THE PONDERED ON. PROVIDE
LOOKING FORWARD NECK. IN OUR
REGION JUST TWENTY MINUTES FROM
THE STATE CAPITAL OF THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE
HAVE MANY AREAS WHERE RESIDENTS
HAVE NO ACCESS TO BROADBAND OR
EVEN CELL PHONE COVERAGE. WE
HAVE THE NUMBER ONE AG
UNIVERSITY. IN THE WORLD ALMOST
AND WE ARE GENERATING GLOBAL
GROUNDBREAKING ACT CHECK BUT WE
CAN'T DEPLOY THE TECHNOLOGIES
IN OUR OWN REGION. TO HELP
FARMERS COMPETE AND SAFE
ENVIRONMENTAL RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT OUR WORLD COMMUNITY.
WITHOUT THE ENABLING TECHNOLOGY
OF BROADBAND. WE HAVE TO MAKE
THAT TO FULLY CONNECT ALL THE
ON THIRD HEALTH IN OUR REGION
WOULD COST MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND TO
PROVIDE CON TO WAIT ON OUR
JOINT YOU THINK ONE. BROADBAND
AND TRANSPORTATION PROJECT MORE
THAN SIXTY SEVEN MILLION THIS
IS JUST. A SLIGHT OF WHAT'S
NEEDED ACROSS. THE STATE AND SO
IT'S A SENSE OF THE MAGNITUDE
IN THE NEED FOR CONTINUED
FUNDING. MORE THAN FORTY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING SEVEN
OF THE REGIONAL BROADBAND
CONSORTIUM FUNDED BY THE BEAUTY
ARE SUPPORTING PASSAGE OF AB
FIVE SEVEN DAYS. PASSAGE WILL
POSITION US FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND LEVERAGE STATE
FUNDING WHICH WILL ALSO BE
CRITICAL TO CONNECT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE HELPFUL. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH WILL
NOT ON TO ANYONE TO FINDS.
DICAS REGARDING THE LAY OF HERE
TECHNO. CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MANSON TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TEST MY MUSLIM LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON
MEMBERS. SO. WE HAD WE'VE HAD
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT NOW WE
WILL BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER THAT WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OKAY
RIGHT NOBODY HERE IN THE ROOM I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A SECOND
WITNESS YOU DID STATE THAT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO- WHO IS YOUR
SECOND WITNESS. EDUARDO
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MAKE THE EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY FUND OKAY IS IT
ORDER GONZALEZ ONLINE. YET MR
GONZALEZ PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S A LOT ON
SALAS ON THE DIRECTOR OF SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY REGIONAL PROP
AND SOCIAL REGIONAL BROADBAND
CONSORTIA REPRESENTS SOME OF
THE MOST WONDERFUL UNDER RIGHT
AREAS OF THIS INCLUDING A COUNT
WITH PERSISTENT POVERTY AN
EXISTING DIGITAL TESTERS TODAY
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SEVENTY BECAUSE EVERYTHING
WE DO MOVING CALIFORNIA FOR
FORWARD WHAT WILL ORBIT ROUND
THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
INTERNET. BUT THE REALITY IN
THE FINAL THE IS THAT MANY EVER
SINCE THEY ARE NOT WITH YOU
THAT CENTRO INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
IT EQUITABLY TO SERVICE WE ALL
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
FUTURE DEPENDS ON INVEST IN
BROADBAND AND YET URBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS AND HOUSE
HOUSEHOLDS IN RURAL AREAS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE LIMITED.
OR NO ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET. AB FLIGHT SO BUT ONLY
CRAPS A BLUEPRINT FOR WITH THE-
MOST MOST IN NEED. OF PROVIDES
THE OP TO THE- EQUITY AUCTION
ACROSS. BIKE THE DIGITAL. SB
FIVE SEVENTY ONE SURE RAPID
DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH
COLLABORATION AMONG.
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
BUILDERS OF INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
STATES PUBLIC SECTOR LEADERS
CONNECT. CONNECT IN CALIFORNIA
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO THE
LEAD THE NATION IN NEXT
GENERATION TECHNOLOGIES TO
COOKING MACTECH. EDUCATION AND
TELL HELL. SB FIVE SEVENTY
OFFICER RESPONSIBLE PATH TO
CHEAP INTERNET CONNECTIVITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AT SPEED
CABLES. THE NEEDS OF FAMILY
COMMUNITIES. AND ECONOMIC TO
BOMB OPPORTUNITIES. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST OR
SOME. THANK YOU VERY NOW WILL
GO TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM A ROOM.
BUT TWENTY FORTY FOR ANYONE
WISH WISHING TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ANYONE
THERE I DON'T SEE A SINGLE
PERSON WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. THE CLERK- CAN YOU Q.
HAVE ANY. SPEAKERS ON THE-
TELECONFERENCE. LEAVE ME MAKERS
ONE AND THEN. MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. OUR FIRST COME INTO
THE PORT COMES FROM LINE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI I THINK I'M THE WRONG. ONE
THREE FORTY ONE. IN LINE ONE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH. ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OR
SUPPORT AB FIVE DO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND LINE TO EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN.PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY TO EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND A DIFFERENT BILL OKAY
THANK YOU. IN LINE TO FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THE RIGHT STANCE
ON BEHALF OF CHEN AND
CALIFORNIA TELL HEALTH NETWORK
A PART OF THE OCEAN FAMILIES
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
IN MY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MOLLY READ SAID WHAT PLAN IN
PLACE TO CALIFORNIAWHERE INTO
PART OF AB. THANK YOU. AT NINE
TO SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ERICA
HOPPING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD.
ACCORDING YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PRIMARY NUMBER YOU KNOW
WHAT YOUR SENIOR CONSTRUCTOR WE
WORKABLE TRAINING INSTITUTE IN
LOS ANGELES AND- WE SUPPORT YOU
MAY EVEN GET TO PLAY. IN LINE
TO NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CRISTINA DO CARRO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SEVENTY. AND MINE TO
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I CAN
LIVE WITH REPRESENTING PHOENIX-
AND COULD COURT AT AB FIVE
SEVENTY AND WORKING WITHOUT
ABOUT THE THREE G. BECAUSE OF
OUR ANCHOR THANK YOU. IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR SENATOR ALLAH
TELL IN THE- ON BEHALF OF LAW
ANGELES THREE TO COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN ORDER BILL. AT NINE
TO SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY THANK YOU. RIGHT IN
LINE THREE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE AWAIT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE ZERO EIGHT. AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LINE. TO NINETY NINE
NINE TO NINETY NINE YEAR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MATE SO LOVE ON BEHALF OF CROWN
CASTLE IN SUPPORT. AND NINE TO
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH THEIR
BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN Q. IT THIS TIME. THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE RE
ANNOUNCE. THE OF THE SPEAKERS
AND SUPPORT WE CAN AGAIN
RENOUNCE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB AB FIVE
SEVENTY PLEASE. CLICK YOUR
PHONES NOW OUR HER INTER ONE
ZERO. ABSOLUTELY IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE A FEW IN THE
QUEUE. A LINE TO NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES PROP IN THE CLEARING
WORKING FOR LABOR MANAGEMENT
CORPORATION AND I FULLY SUPPORT
THAT YOU'D BE AYE CLEANS HE
REQUIRED IN THE BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. IN LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHICH CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREG COOK REPRESENTING IN THE
GOLDEN STATE OUR COOPERATIVE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY. VERY WELL- WE'RE GOING
TO FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS FOR
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY LEAD SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR DO WE
KNOW OF ANY A LEAD SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I WON
ON THE PHONE EVERY. I AM I'M
WHILE ONE OF THE- WITH A LOT OF
THIS ON THE PHONE I CAN HEAR
ME. YES WHAT IS YOUR NAME BUT
INTERESTED BUCKLE AND THEN I
GOING PROCEED HONEST HERE. YES
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY THANK YOU
HI MISTER SHARON AND MEMBERS MY
NAME'S ARE AT THE TOP OWN I'M
THE SENIOR LET'S SAY COUNSEL
FOR THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION I A I BRING WITH ME
FIFTEEN YEARS OF
TELECOMMUNICATION POLICY
EXPERIENCE INCLUDING SERVING ON
THE FEDERAL LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE TO DRAFT OF THE FIRST
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM A FELLOWSHIP IT'LL
FIBER FELLOWSHIP WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN ALL THE PLANNING AND
RESEARCH TO DEVELOP THE STATE'S
FIRST TELECOMMUNICATIONS
POLICIES FOR THE GENERAL PLAN
GUIDELINE. EFF IN MAJORITY THE
OPPOSITION THIS BILL SPACING IT
IS NOT BECAUSE IT FUND'S.
PROFIT INFRASTRUCTURE WE
SUPPORT THAT. IT'S BILL WAS TO
PROVIDE A SPECIAL EMPHASIS ON
THE PURE ACT POPULAR WE WOULD
SUPPORT THAT TO. OUR CONCERN IS
THAT HIGH OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THIS BILL IS SEEKING TO
FINANCIAL STATE MONEY. WITH A
NEW PRIORITY COST EFFECTIVE
TWENTY FIGHT THE METRIC THIS
METRIC WILL NOT PUSH FIBER
OPTICS INTO ON SIR COMMUNITIES.
FIBER BEING THE COURT
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT LITERALLY%
ALL MODERN NETWORK TODAY ARE
USING TO ENABLE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ACCESS. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE FIBER IS NOT A TWENTY
FOUR YOU CONNECTION IT IS A
TRANSFORMATIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT PROVIDE HIGH CAPACITY
ACCESS. A PRIOR TWENTY FIVE
THREE COST EFFECTIVE STANDARD
ESSENTIALLY REPRESENTS TWO
TYPES OF NETWORK DEPLOYMENT.
THE FIRST IS UPGRADING COPPER
LINES FROM THE OLD TELEPHONE
SYSTEM CALLED DSL. DOES KIND
ASSISTANCE AND THEY ARE BEING
ABANDONED BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
TODAY IN FAVOR OF FIBER OPTICS
IN A SCENE VETERAN AND
UPGRADING THOSE NETWORKS. WHICH
WOULD BE A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
WASTE THE- IS OPERATING
CELLPHONE. BY CONNECTING WITH
FIBER AND AS TO THIRTY MILES
OUTSIDE OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
WHICH IS ALREADY MANDATED UNDER
TEAM MOBILE'S MURDER-
CONDITIONS WITH SPRINT. WHICH
MEANS PRIVATE DOLLARS WITHOUT
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT OR BUILDING
OUT THIS NETWORK IN THE FEDERAL
LAW. PUSHING FIBER ENTITIES
COMMUNITIES SHOULD BE THE PARTY
OF ANY GOVERNMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM AND
EVERY DOLLAR SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON BUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WE NEED TO END THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THE BEST WAY FOR ME TO
HELP EXPLAIN KIND OF THE
CONSEQUENCE OF DIFFERENT TO
THESE APPROACHES. IS THE POINT
TO THE STORY ABOUT OF THE TINY
TOWN OF DILLON BEACH
CALIFORNIA. THEIR FATHER CHILD
NEED INTERNET MUCH LIKE ANY
REAL COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO OUR
SCHOOL WORK. HE DECIDED THAT HE
WHAT HE WAS GOING TO DO IS GET
A FIBRE LINE CONNECTED TO HIS
GARAGE FROM A CELL TOWER OF
EIGHTEEN HE OWNED. A TOWER THAT
WAS A FRACTION AWAY FROM HOME.
FOR TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
CONNECTED IT HOUSE AND THEN
REALIZE THAT SINGLE FIBER LINE
ONE LINE. GIVE THEM SO MUCH
BANDWIDTH. BUT HE WAS ABLE TO
START A GARAGE BASED ICE T. FOR
COMMUNITY HAD NO INTERNET. WITH
OFF THE SHELF HARDWARE. THAT
WAS THREE YEARS AGO AND TODAY
IN THAT. COUNTY BEFORE TO
PEOPLE. PEOPLE HAVE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MEGABIT DOWNLOAD ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MEGABIT UPLOAD
WIRELESS BROADBAND. OR FIFTY
DOLLARS A MONTH. GET A TRAVEL.
MILES OUT TO DRAW THAT FIBER
AND AB FIVE SEVENTY LEAD OUT
ITS INFRASTRUCTURE POLICY. IT
COSTS WOULD EXCEED A MILLION
DOLLARS MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE
SERVICE COMMUNITY. THIS BILL IS
RENDON NOT MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT
TOWARDS THE FUTURE THAT WE
NEED. IT DIVERTS FROM AN
UNNECESSARILY AND IT FEELS NONE
OF THE PROPOSED BENEFIT THAT
ARE BEING ASSERTIVE ARTICLES. I
KNOW SOME SUPPORTING THAT
LEGISLATION ARE WILL ARGUE THAT
THE NUMBERS DON'T MEAN ANYTHING
BUT THAT THAT IS CATEGORICALLY
WRONG. THE NUMBERS IN THE BILL
DICTATE YOUR EXPECT YOUR
POLICY. AND THE STATE AGES ARE
VIEWING THIS EFFORT MUCH LIKE
WE DO THE ROADS. ARE CONNECTING
POUNDS OF THE ROAD ENABLE
COMMERCE AND SELF SUFFICIENCY.
AND EVERY DOLLAR SHOULD BE
DIRECTED TOWARDS BUILDING THE.
ROAD AND THAT ROAD TODAY IS
FIBER. SHOULD SB FIVE. TO
AROUND PUSH JUST EVEN A-
PIPELINE TO. RULE UNSERVED TOWN
WITH ZERO AXIS WE WOULD SUPPORT
IT AND PUT MANY WHO OPPOSE THE
UNLIMITED RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE A MASSIVE STEP
TOWARD.ALL COME RESOLUTIONS
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. WE HAVE
WORKED IN PLACE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR HAND FOR
NOW WE ARE POSTING ONCE
AMENDED. WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL WE WANT TO SUPPORT AT
ELEVEN THIRTY BOTH OF THESE CAN
BE DONE TOGETHER- BUT A AND B.
FOCUS ON CONNECTING THE ANSWER
TO THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT ARE PRESENT
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE PRESENT IN THE
CHAMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB FIVE
SEVENTY. ANYONE AT ALL WILL
MOVE ON TO- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
IN TWENTY FORTY I DON'T SEE
ANYONE. IN THE ROOM SO WE WILL
MOVE ON. TO THOSE OF THEIR ON
THE CALL. MODERATOR FEUD PLEASE
PRINT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE SEVENTY.
AS SOON AS WE DO WE WILL HEAR
THE OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEIR AT THIS
TIME. YEAH IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY YOU WOULD PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MODERATOR JUST A FEW MOMENTS
WHILE WE GATHER NINE. OKAY
MODERATOR SOON AS THEY- Q. AND
COULD YOU- PLEASE INFORMACIóN
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ON. WAITING
TO SPEAK. WE HAVE EIGHT. VERY
WELL FOR EVERYONE CAN STATE
THEIR NAME AND WHO THE
REPRESENTING AND THE POSITION
ON THE BILL A MODERATOR PLEASE
BEGIN TO Q. IN THE SPEAKERS.
THANK YOU. IN LINE TWO SEVENTY
FIVE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
TWO SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- CHAIR- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS YOLANDA
BENTON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR AND WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFTEN WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION AND WE
ARE NOW NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND
WE THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF FOR BEING AVAILABLE AND
WORKING WITH THAT. THANK YOU.
VERY WELL MODERATOR NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE OPEN THE LINES.
AT NINE TO EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. IN MY NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KNOW WHAT HOWARD ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION EIGHTY
FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU. YEAH AND
NINE TO SEVENTY THREE YEAR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING
THAT COMMONSENSE WE ARE CLOSE
LESS AMENDED THANK YOU. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WENT
AND LAY WITH THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE WE OPPOSE THE
MANDATE. THANK YOU. IN NINETY
THREE. FIVE NINETY TWO SEVEN A
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE MEMBERS THIS IS STEVE
SEVERAL CLOSE BROADBAND
CONSORTIUM WE OPPOSE THE LAST
AMEND. IN LINE THREE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND%
MEMBERS CAROLINE MCINTYRE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED
THE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH THE OP
CARE TO ADDRESS MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE BRING. AND MINE
TO TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL B.
TERRACE ON BEHALF TURN WITHIN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE SEVENTY AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR COULD WOULD
YOU PLEASE. AGAIN ASK FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO. SPEAKER COULD
YOU PROP THE SPEAKERS
ABSOLUTELY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE SEVENTY AND WISH TO
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER. OPPOSITION COMMENTS
IN Q. OKAY THANK. QUESTION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
REGARDING THIS MEASURE WE HAVE
A SENATOR STERN ON THE LINE AS
WELL. TO HAVE- CENTER STERN WE
SEE YOUR HAND THERE. RAISED YES.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I THANK YOU SIMPLY
MEMBER FOR. DAHLE YOUR WORK NOT
JUST THIS YEAR BUT OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS TRYING TO
CONQUER THIS DIGITAL DIVIDE I
I'M JUST I'M WONDERING IF YOU
COULD COMMENT ON- THIS QUESTION
WAS RAISED ABOUT THE- TWENTY
FIVE THREE SPLIT BEING
INADEQUATE AND- I KNOW IT'S A
BIG DEAL. OUT IN YOUR NECK OF
THE WOODS IN RURAL AREAS AND WE
HAVE IT IN BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
AREAS AND- WITH PEOPLE ALSO
TRYING TO. CALL IN FOR SCHOOL
NOW AND ALL THE TELECOMMUTING
THAT HAS TO HAPPEN BUT
ESPECIALLY FOR. PHARMACY SB A
PERSPECTIVE I'M JUST CURIOUS-
HOW WE DEAL WITH. IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE YOU'RE IN A SPOT WHERE
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT'S-
FEASIBLE IN THE NEAR TERM BUT
MAYBE NOT ASPIRATIONAL ENOUGH
TO REALLY CLOSE THAT DIVIDES
SO- YOU MIGHT RISING COMMENTS
ARE YOU OR YOUR YOUR SPONSORS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE SCHOOL
BOARD'S FOLKS. SURE I'LL LET MY
SPONSOR- IS USING MY SPEAKER
EITHER TRISH FOR DISTURBANCE
SPEAK BEFORE THEY DO THAT IS
THAT. COMING UP WITH THE SPEED
IS NOT ME IS NOT THE TO TIRE
FOLK THIS. WE TO RE IS THAT IT
REALLY HAVE LOT TO DO WITH THE
FUNDING. IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY YOU CAN'T. BILLS AND SO.
IT'S ALREADY IN. FOR FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ON
MILLION DOLLARS THE PEOPLE OF
APPLIED TO MOVE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS ALONG BUT THE FUND
ONLY HAS LIKE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY WILL NEVER WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH SO IT'S NOT GOING TO GET
EVERYBODY COVERED. AND I ALWAYS
LOOK AT THESE THINGS IS THAT-
WE NEED TO LOOK AT- GIVING THE
BEST AND I THINK FARMERS A WAY
TO DO THAT IT'S GOING TO HELP
US TO THE FUTURE- OF RIGHT NOW
I WON SAID TWENTY FIVE THREE
GREAT- BUT WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE ANY SERVICE AT ALL
RIGHT NOW THE IMPORTANT TO THIS
BILL IS TO MAKE SURE WE GET
PEOPLE THAT ARE. NOT SERVED GET
THEM SERVE AND I DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE I'M GOING WITH THIS IS
THAT ITS IMPORTANCE IS THE
SPEED IMPORTANT ABSOLUTELY- BUT
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER IS THAT.
BELIEVE SOMEBODY BUT- IT
EVERYBODY GETS A LOT OF A BAND
WITH WE'RE GONNA LEAVE SOME OF.
THE MOST OF THE RURAL AREAS IN
EVEN URBAN AREAS BEHIND. SO ALL
THE- MISS A- KELLY- GONZALEZ
REPEAT ISN'T AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. THE TRUTH OF THE
MATTER IS THAT THE REASON
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND PROJECTS APPROVED BY THE
P. YOU SEE. I HAVE ALL ALMOST
ALL BEEN FIRED WITH PROJECT SO
WITH THAT IT'S RATHER A MOOT
POINT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
BECAUSE THAT'S. THE PROJECT
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON IN THE
REGION TO GET BY THE- ENABLING
BOB HERTZBERG MIDDLE MILE. PER
IT'S ALSO GOING TO HELP THE
DRAWING EACH REACH THE GOAL WE
ARE. VERY PACKED ABOUT TRYING
TO OUR COVER IN OUR MANY MANY
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED AREAS
BUT ALSO WE ARE ASPIRATIONAL WE
WANT THE BEST FOR OUR COMMUNITY
AND WE'RE TRYING TO PROMOTE.
NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT ELLA TO
BREAK THE ISSUE SELECT
COMMITTEE SO. I THINK IT'S OUR
IT'S OUR- MISSTATED TO SAY THAT
THE BILL BRING. BACK IT BRING
THAT FORWARD. AND IT PROVIDES
THE FUNDING RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO. THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE BEING
DEPLOYED NOW ARE. ALMOST BY THE
GREAT THE PROJECT THAT THE
CATHOLIC THE FUNDING. THANK YOU.
OKAY VERY SERVICE CENTERS. ARE
YOU SUGGESTING THAT YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANKS FOR
THAT THE- RESPONSE I GUESS MY
STRUGGLE WITH WITH THE
LEGISLATION IS THAT I LOVE THE
FUNDING PORTION AND I THINK YOU
GUYS HAVE DONE A REALLY GOOD
JOB OF BUILDING A FRAMEWORK
THAT ERROR I JUST. TAKE A
MINUTE NAP IS THERE ANY
OPENNESS TO GOING BEYOND THE
TWENTY FIVE THREE AND HAVING
SOMETHING MORE ASPIRATIONAL
PERHAPS IN LINE WITH WHAT WE
PASSED THROUGH THE SENATE- ANY
OF VERSION TO TRYING TO SORT OF
HAVE. GREEN WITH ALL YOUR
PURPOSES HERE JUST CURIOUS AND-
I'LL SEE MY REMARKS AFTER THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OKAY
VERY WELL. THE ASPIRATIONS IS
TO GET AS FAST AS WE CAN WE'RE
NOT. DOING NOW SAW OUT OF OUR
HOUSE- THE FACT THE MATTER IS
IT TWENTY FIVE THREE IS
REASONABLE TO FEDERAL
STANDARDS. WE CAN GO FROM MORE
THAN THAT BUT WE NEED TO BE A
REALISTIC AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
MY GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
FASTER SPEEDS. FOR FAMILIES
CAN. USE THE INTERNET AT HOME
OR TELL HEALTH OR WHATEVER BUT
WE DO NEED TO HAVE A FASTER.
OUR OLD SPEEDS WERE JUST TOO
SLOW. BUT STILL DIDN'T MEAN
ANYTHING TO MY DISTRICT THEY
THEY'RE STILL UNDERSERVED OR
NOT SERVED. BUT VERY AND OTHER
MY OF THE THAT'S OSCAR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANTED TO-
THANK YOU AND THE COMMITTEE-STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL
BECAUSE I THINK THE AMENDMENTS
TO IMPROVE IT. AND I GUESS I
WOULD. ASK AGAIN I- AS MY
COLLEAGUE- SENATOR STERN- I.
ARE TOTALLY APPRECIATE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE. AND
APPRECIATE ANY. THAT WE HAVE SO
MANY AREAS IT THAT- JUST DON'T
EVEN HAVE SERVICE SO THE
FEDERAL SPEED AT WAY YOU KNOW
WHAT OF COURSE. THAT'S OF
COURSE WHAT WE WANT AT MINIMUM
BUT GIVEN THAT HE ASKED ABOUT
THE ASPIRATIONAL GOAL MAN I
THINK THAT IF WE ARE GOING TO
BE. INVESTING IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THE GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCE FOR
FACING NOW AND GIVEN WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT KIDS NEEDS FOR.
ONLINE LEARNING IN THE REST
THAT. WE SHOULD BE DOING OUR
VERY BEST TO GET THAT HIGH
SPEED AND SO AGAIN I WANT TO
ASK ABOUT THAT OPENNESS BECAUSE
THERE'RE- BEEN THROUGH WAS VERY
CHANGES TO THE BILL BUT THERE
POTENTIALLY. COULD BE
ADDITIONAL THAT DOES THAT STILL
MEET YOUR GOALS BUT GET US
TOWARDS THAT THAT FASTER. I'M
NOT. I'M NOT THE THING THAT WE
CAN ONLY BE A TWENTY FIVE THREE.
BUT SO FAR THIS THE- MY GOD IS
THAT'S I'VE SPOT FOR US TO GO
AS WE MOVE FORWARD- DO WE HAVE
ASPIRATIONS TO GO FASTER DO WE
HAVE ASPIRATIONS TO BE ABLE TO
THE FIBER CAN USE ANY KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY IS TIMES CHANGE I
MEAN EVEN IN THE SHORT. TIME WE
DID SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE IT'S
CHANGE OUR TECH CHANGE AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE IS
BECAUSE WHAT WE TRIED BEFORE
DIDN'T NECESSARILY WORK SO THE
OPERATIONS ARE TO GO TO DO
BETTER BUT THE FACT IS THAT
RIGHT NOW. AND SIX ONE. AT THE
TO GET EVERYBODY TO BE AT ABOUT
SPEED TO BE ABLE TO A WORK FROM
HOME OR WHATEVER BUT IF IT IS
AN ASPIRATION TO GO FARTHER
THAN THAT BUT LET'S FACE IT
THIS WE GOT TO START SOMEWHERE
TWENTY THREE THE FEDERAL
STANDARD AND WE LIKE TO DO REAL
THIS. ON THE PHONE DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS TRISH. YES YEAH
THANK YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THE PROJECT THAT
HAVE BEEN FUNDED BY CATHERINE
THAT OUR FINAL PROJECT I READ
THE PRINTED ARE BEYOND BY THREE
SO THE FINE IS ALL EXCEEDING
BACK. BUT LEVEL. AND GOING
HIRING AN ADVOCATE. TO GO MUCH
HIGHER UP TO GET A BIT. SOLD
OUT VIRGINITY IS DEFINITELY
THERE. CENTER SKINNER. OKAY
VERY WELL ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE A CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I GOT
STUCK ON SOMETHING INTO
SOMETHING ELSE AND SOME LATE
NIGHT IDEA MAY HAVE BEEN
REPETITIVE BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT- FOR THE
CONVERSATION. THE CENTER
SKINNER KNOWS TWO MINUTE
MENTION THIS IS PART OF THE-
COMIC. GROUP WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE BOTH
BETWEEN BOTH HOUSES AND THE
RELEASE THAT WENT OUT ON MONDAY
ARTICULATED THE NEED SET FORTH
IN THIS MEASURE. THERE'S AN
INTEREST IN THIS HOUSE. BY
SENATOR COVER HEROES. GONZALEZ
TOGETHER WITH THIS MEASURE AND
MEMBER- MURATSUCHI. A WE'VE HAD
A SERIES OF CONVERSATIONS. TO
PUT TOGETHER A LARGER FRAME. TO
INCLUDE THIS IN TO THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PACKAGE SO ICE ICE I.
SANSOM SUPPORTERS MEASURE TODAY
AND APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS AND
THINK THAT THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT THIS COULD
BE A WAY TO SECURE TIES A
REVENUE STREAM. AND REALLY
PROVIDE- THE ACCESS THAT WE
NEED FOR PARTICULARLY FOR
UNDERSERVED IN FOR TROUBLE SO
SINCE FOR BUT I WANTED TO SHARE
THAT. PART OF THE- HOUSE. IF IT
HASN'T ALREADY BEEN SAID I
APOLOGIZE. CENTER WINNER. THANK
YOU AYE RESEARCHER ARE ALL THE
VOTING FOR THIS OUR CITY FOR
THIS BILL TODAY I DO I SHARE
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN ARTICULATED- THE
AMENDMENTS- ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS- AND I'M GONNA GO FOR
THIS TODAY- TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING SO THE
AUTHOR AND CENTER GONZALEZ THE
TWO HOUSES CAN WORK THROUGH
THAT I'M CONFIDENT WE'LL GET
THERE I IN THE FUNDING. AND
THIS BILL IS GREAT. SO I BUT I
DO- WANT TO REITERATE- WORKING
WITH OTHERS- DIVING CENTER
STERN. REFERRED TO IT AS
ASPIRATIONAL- I WOULD REFER TO
IT IS AS ESSENTIAL. ON BECAUSE
THE HISTORY. OF THE INTERNET.
AND CELL SERVICE AND EVERYTHING
ELSE IN THIS COUNTRY IS THAT
WERE ALWAYS BEHIND AND WE'RE
CONSTANTLY IT SEEMS INVESTING
AND AL DATED. TECHNOLOGY AN
OUTDATED INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE
SEE THIS WITH SOME OF OUR
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
THEIR VARIOUS. ECONOMIC REASONS
FOR IT BUT IT ENDS UP BEING A
WE'RE BEHIND AS A COUNTRY WE'RE
SEEING THIS PLAY OUT NOW- AND
THERE ARE THE- PEOPLE AND THE
KIDS. WHO LACKEY. YOU TOTALLY
LIKE AN AXE OR EVER SLOW. OR
BUT JUST WHO HAVE WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED NORMAL INTERNET.
SERVICE AND IT'S STILL
TERRIBLE- AND THEIR WIFI IS
JUST TERRIBLE IN THEIR PEOPLE
WHO YOU KNOW HAVE RESOURCES
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO PAY AND
STILL HAVE TERRIBLE SERVICE
COULD NEVER THE ONLY HAVE ONE
PROVIDER. AND IT'S TERRIBLE
HORRIBLE SERVICE AND IT'S SLOW
IN ITS GLITCH AND NETWORKS.
PEOPLE TO LEARN- AND GO TO WORK
AND DO EVERYTHING ELSE AND EVEN
ONCE THE PANDEMIC IS OVER AND
IT WILL BE THANKFULLY A AND-
GOD WILLING AND- WE WILL STILL.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE BEHIND
BEHIND BEHIND I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE. I'VE DIED OUT AS WE- TOP.
FIVE PEOPLE ARE HURTING IGHT
NOW AND BECAUSE THEY LOCKERS
ACCESS I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR
FOR. FOR FIGHTING FOR THIS I
WANNA MAKE SURE REALLY LIFTING
THEM UP INTO. THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND I AGREE THE FIBER
IS ABSOLUTELY- ESSENTIAL SOLVE
THE SUPPORTERS TODAY. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT OF THAT THE
AUTHORS WILL WORK TOGETHER- AND
GODSPEED IN DOING THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE YOU
KNOW JUST A FEW COMMENTS OF MY
OWN THE- IT'S LOW IT'S
LAMENTABLE TO HEAR THE COMMENTS
OF THE OPPOSITION AND I WOULD
HAVE WISHED. THAT WE COULD FIND
A BILL THAT COULD BRING IN. THE
THEIR SUPPORT ON BOARD. WITH
THIS BILL THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
VERY IMPORTANT THERE THERE ARE
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS AND HAVE. A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN MAKING SURE
WE HAVE ACCESS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE I'VE BEEN PERSONALLY
DEALING NETWORK WITH DEALING
WITH THIS FOR TEN YEARS AND AS
CHAIR FOR AT LEAST A- SIX YEARS.
AND IT'S VERY SENSITIVE ISSUE
IT'S VERY HARD TO PERFECT IT'S
VERY HARD TO WRITE A BILL THAT
COVERS ALMOST EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE AND OFTENTIMES WE
WANT TO PRIORITIZE SO IS IT
IMPROVING SPEED IS VERY
IMPORTANT IMPROVING ACCESS IS
VERY IMPORTANT HOW DO YOU DO
ALL THAT COST EFFECTIVELY
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY
IN A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE HAVE- A VERY DIVERSE
STATE BUT ALSO. IN A VERY LARGE
INCOME. DISPARITIES AND
GEOGRAPHICAL DISPARITIES AS
WELL FROM FROM HIGH DESERT TO
LOW DOES OR TO- HIGH MOUNTAIN
RANGE TO THE URBAN. A VERY
POPULATED URBAN CENTERS AND
IT'S A VERY HARD STATE TO SERVE
IN TERMS OF INTERNET BUT THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PROJECT TO
TO TACKLE SOY I GIVE LOTS OF
KUDOS TO THE AUTHOR. FOR TAKING
THIS ISSUE ON INCH ATTEMPTING
TO MAKE IT BETTER I FEEL. THAT
THIS BILL A TAKES A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL
HAVE MORE SUCCESS WITH THIS.
IT'S LIKE I SAID THERE IS NO
PERFECT SCIENCE TO HOW TO DO
THIS. IN A WAY THAT WILL GET
EVERYBODY SUPPORT AND I WISH WE
CAN GET CLOSER TO DOING THAT.
EVEN OUR BEST LOOKING WITH THE
AUTHOR HAS BEEN VERY OPEN TAKE.
VERY IMPORTANT WHAT I CONSIDER
VERY IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS TO
HELP- TARGET- CERTAIN AREAS
THAT ARE SO IMPORTANT TO US
INCLUDING BRINGING MORE PEOPLE
ON BOARD. TO GETTING ACCESS TO
INTERNET ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
TIME WHEN WE NEED OUR OUR
CHILDREN TO HAVE ACCESS TO
DISTANCE LEARNING. SO I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY AND THE COMMITTEE LIKE
O MAKE A MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION BY. SENATOR HERTZBERG
AYE CENTER HILL DID YOU WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION WELCOME BACK TO THE
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY WOMAN ARE OR
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS FOR MAYBE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
YOU KNOW ALL MAKE IT REALLY
QUICK BECAUSE I KNOW ROOMS
READY TO GET OUT OF HERE BY I
JUST WANT TO THINK. YOU STAFF
OF THE CENTER FOR WORKING BUT
THIS REALLY HAPPY THE.
KNOWLEDGE HOW DO THIS IS AN BUT
THE AGAIN SO LEANING INVOLVES
MY HAD MORE COMMERCE. ARE WE
DONE NO ARE WE YOU KNOW GOING
TO WORK TOGETHER ABSOLUTELY WE
COMMITTED THAT TOGETHER AND I
THINK WE CAN COME OUT WITH A
REAL GOOD BILL AS WELL MAKE
SURE THAT WE HIT ALL THE THINGS
WE TO. I JUST WANT TO SAY IS
YOU KNOW. RIGHT HOPE IT THAT
THE I MY VOICE IS A CRACK WITH.
IT WAS A LOT OF KIDS THAT ARE
STE. OUT THERE. AND INTEL
HEALTH. I MEAN HOW CAN WE WALK
AWAY FROM PEOPLE THAT ARE USING
TELEHEALTH. IN RIGHT NOW DURING
COVERT DOCTORS ARE SAYING
EIGHTEEN TWENTY PEOPLE A DAY
JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN DO IT
TELEHEALTH. AND SO WE HAVE A-
WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
PEOPLE. AND IT'S AN EQUITY
ISSUE AND SO I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYBODY IS THAT WE'LL
GET THERE. WILL THERE BE FIX IS
TO THIS WE DIDN'T THINK SIXTY
SIXTY FIVE WOULD DO IT. WE
TRIED WE DID THE BEST WE COULD.
WELCOME TO WORK ON THESE AND
I'M SURE THIS IS NOT THE END OF
THE BILLS WE WILL BE WORKING ON.
I WILL. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MùT TO AS AMENDED TO PROVIDE
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FIVE SEVENTY TO PASS TO BE
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WESSEL BY WESSEL I MORE NOT.
MOORLACH NO. CENTER MORE LIKE
HE'S SPEAKER MICROPHONE. AB YOU
MIGHT WANT TO HAVE ADRIAN.
TICKET IN THE REMARKABLE. THANK
YOU MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD I. CHEN HELLO. CHEN
THOUGH. DOLLY NO TELLING THEM.
DOT HI. DOT FIVE. HERTZBERG.
PLEASE HI. HERTZBERG I. HILL HI
HILL I SAID MCGUIRE YEAH I KNOW
RUBIO. SKINNER I. STERN.
INTERNET VOTING. SENATOR STERN
NOT VOTING. WIENER HI WIENER I.
SEVEN EYES THREE KNOWS ONE NOT
VOTING CHAIR OKAY THAT BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR. AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING. AND WE HAVE- SUPPORTERS
FOR MINOR STAND LEAD SUPPORTERS
SCOTT WHICH MAYOR MARION
MORTGAGE MORTGAGE SAN. AND THE
LEAD OPPOSITION IS MARKED TONI
AND COREY BULLIS AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE.
WAS STANDING BY READY TO SPEAK-
WE WILL HEAR FROM THE PRESENTER
NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING PLEASE
PROCEED WATER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRPERSON JUST WANNA THANK
YOU AND ALL YOUR STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
AS I DISCUSSED YOUR TEAM I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE MEMBERS WITH
THE TO THE OFFICE. OF REFORM BY
COMMITTEE STAFF AND MY STAFF
THIS WILL PRESERVE THE SECTIONS
THAT ENSURE. UNSPENT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY FUNDS ARE USED TO
THE SCHOOL. AS WELL PROVISIONS
THE STATE FUNDED ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGERS ARE SAFELY
INSTALLED WITH A TRAINED
WORKFORCE. THIS BILL EXPEDITES
EVEY CHARGING INSTALLATIONS AND
HELP SCHOOLS REPAIR REPLACE
INEFFICIENT HEATING AND AIR
SYSTEMS ARE WATER FIXTURES. AB
EIGHT FOUR ONE MORE TEMPORARILY
REDUCE UNUSED I OWE YOU ENERGY
EFFICIENCY DOLLARS TO CREATE A
GRANT. PROGRAM FOR SCHOOLS TO
REPAIR AND REPLACE OUTDATED
HEATING AND AIR SYSTEMS AND
INEFFICIENT. WATER FIXTURES.
MILLIONS OF THE DOLLAR CURRY
SIT IN THE CPUC ELEVEN ON
SPENT. FOR YEARS. WE'D LIKE TO
PUT THOSE DOLLARS TO WORK. ABLE
TO WORK AS WELL AS HELP OUR
SCHOOLS DURING THIS TIME.
DISADVANTAGED FULL REEVES PERCY
FIRST PRIORITY FOR MONEY. FOR
VENTILATION IN SCHOOLS EXPOSE
CHILDREN AND TEACHERS FIGURE
PLUMES WILDFIRE SMOKE ALLERGENS
AND WEBER COVERT NINETEEN
LINGER IN THE AIR. AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE WILL ALSO EXPERT AT
THE INSTALLATION OF VB CHARTERS
ARE MAKING PERMITTED A CPUC
DECISION TO PROTECT RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS WITH ALL THE CHARGES
FOR BRING. ACCESS FEES REQUIRED
THE CPC TO RENEW DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE DURING AN AUTO
YOU GENERAL RAPE CASE INSTEAD
OF A ONE OFF TV PLANTS. THE
REQUIRED THE CPUC TO APPROVE OR
DENY EDISON IN SD GT'S LONG
PENDING EVEY PLANS BARTON FIRST.
LAST WE DO START WE ALSO DO NOT
TELL THE CPUC HOW TO RESOLVE.
THE APPLICATIONS ONLY THAT THEY
DO SO IN A TIMELY FASHION.
THESE CHARGES WAS STRUCK BY THE
INSTALLATION THESE CHANGES WILL
INSTRUMENT INFLATION THE
CHARGERS. HELP ATTRACT PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. LASTLY THE BILL
ENSURE THE EEVEE CHARTERS
INSTALLED WITH THE STATE FUNDS
WILL HAVE AT LEAST ONE PERSON
TRAINED. TO FIFTH REINSTALL
EVEY CHARGER THROUGH THE
NATIONAL USED ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAINING
PROGRAM. WITHOUT AYE WELCOME MY
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION. MISTER WELCH AS
WELL AS A- IN A BARGAIN SENT ON
BEHALF OF THE- NRDC VERY WELL
WE'LL START WITH MR WHICH-
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE MEMBER
SCOTT WAY TO BE AT THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. CALIFORNIA STATE PIKE
TRADES COUNCIL AND WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS AND THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE CAME OUT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE CLIMATE
SUBCOMMITTEE. IT'S ABOUT TWO
THINGS CREATING CLEAN ENERGY
JOBS IN ADDRESSING URGENT
ISSUES AROUND COVE IN NINETEEN.
THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY COMPONENT
OF AB EIGHT FORTY ONE COMES
DIRECTLY FROM THE UC DAVIS
ENERGY EFFICIENCY INSTITUTES
WHITE PAPER ON SCHOOL THE
OPENING. THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONTROL'S VENTILATION
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR RE OPENING.
AND THE GAO JULY REPORT TO
CONGRESS THE FOUND THE 41% OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS NEED
VENTILATION AND H. BACK SYSTEM
REPLACEMENTS. WE KNOW THAT
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
DEPRESSION AND COLLAPSING
PROPERTY VALUES THE TO SEEP
SEIZE CURRENT P. SET OF
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO BE
DRASTICALLY UNDER UTILIZED. AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE OR TO RE DIRECT
THE UNUSED PORTIONS OF THESE
PRECIOUS DOLLARS TO MAKING OUR
SCHOOLS SAFE FOR RE OPENING. B
FORTY ONE WOULD PRETTY MUCH
NEEDED JOBS BY DIRECTING THE
CPUC TO CONCLUDE THEIR
DECISIONS ON THE NEXT WAVE OF
EVEY CHARGING STATIONS BY SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC IN EDISON BY
MARCH FIRST. THESE ARE. HAVE
BEEN LANGUISHING FOR MORE THAN
TWO YEARS. A RECENT STUDY BY
SYNAPSE FOUND THAT IF YOU LOOK
AT ALL THE EEVEE CHARGING
STATIONS INSTALLED BY THE I. O.
U.'S. THEY HAVE RETURNED EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
DIRECTLY BACK TO RATE PAYERS.
FOR AB EIGHT FORTY ONE WOULD
ENSURE SAFETY OF THESE CHARGING
STATIONS BY CODIFYING THE CPU
SEES OWN SAFETY GUIDELINES THE
UTILIZED EVEY I. T. P.
CERTIFICATIONS. THE
CERTIFICATION DEVELOPED BY THE
ELECTRIC CAR INDUSTRY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE AFTER A
SERIES OF GARAGE FIRES HAVE
BEEN MANDATED IN OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
INSTALLATIONS AND CAL. THE
TRICK PROVIDED BY UTILITIES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ANY I. B. W.
TO UNION AND NONUNION
TECHNICIANS IT IS VERY
INEXPENSIVE. WE URGE IN EITHER
THANK YOU. NOW WE'LL GO TO
MARIAN BERGESON. ON THE LINE.
PLEASE Q. MARIAN BERGESON. I AM
HERE THANK YOU HUESO AND
SENATORS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT SEND YOUR SCIENTISTS
BUT AT OUR DC TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
ONE THIS BILL ACCELERATES THE
DEPLOYMENT OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR ALL TYPES OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND FOSTERS
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN ELECTRIC
INDUSTRY LABOR AND INDEPENDENT
FIRMS TO MEET THE STATE AIR
QUALITY IN CLIMATE GOALS. THIS
BILL ALSO DIRECTS FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED BY THE PC
FOR USE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ALLOCATED TO PROGRAMS IN ORDER
TO REPAIR AND REPLACE HEATING
COOLING AND VENTILATION SYSTEMS
IN SCHOOL. IT ALSO PROVIDES
FUNDS REPLACE AGING AND
INEFFICIENT WATER FIXTURES
SAVING WATER AND ENERGY WHILE
REDUCING EXPOSURE TO LEAD.
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL FOCUSES
ON BENEFITING SCHOOLS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FIRST.
THESE IMPROVEMENTS ARE ALIGNED
TO THE CUP IN NINETEEN SPECIFIC
GUIDELINES FROM THE CDC AN
ASHTRAY. UPGRADE TO ALSO
GENERALLY IMPROVE THE LEARNING
CONDITIONS IN SCHOOLS. BECAUSE
CORAL VENTILATION HARMS ABILITY
TO PAY ATTENTION. AND THE
FILTER THAT IT WILL REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF WILDFIRE SMOKE. IN
THIS TIME AT THE HOTEL AND
ECONOMIC CRISES RE DIRECTING A
PORTION OF ENERGY EFFICIENCY
FUNDS FOR A PERIOD OF JUST
THREE YEARS. WHY WORKERS AND TO
MAKE SCHOOLS SAFER AND MORE
ENERGY EFFICIENT AND THE TIMELY
AND URGENT INVESTMENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MISS LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. OF NOW LET'S BEGIN
HERE WITH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS FOR. AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE ANNOUNCE
WITNESSES OR CAN YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT
FORTY ONE. ABSOLUTELY AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS. WE DO I OUR FIRST
LINE IS THAT OF. LINE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE HOW MANY SPEAKERS
TO HAVE ON THE LINE. SO FAR I
IT IS SEVENTY FIVE IN RAISING.
OKAY WE ASK SPEAKERS TO PLEASE
THE STATE YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING. AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THAT- PLEASE CALL
THE FOR SPEAKER. NINE TO THIRTY
NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY MINUTES LATER
MEMBERS. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SCHOOL. THE NEXT
SPEAKER. NINE TWO FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
WHAT YOU CALL THOSE WITH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PIKE ST STE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD SO WITH A
RP CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
OPPOSITION THE BILL. NINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR MY NAME IS OSCAR QUE LIVING
CARSON CALIFORNIA I'M NOT A
CHRISTIAN. AND I AM THE SUPPORT
OF LEVY ARE TO BE REQUIREMENTS
FOR BILL OR ONE. NINE ONE
THIRTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DANIEL UNION AND I'M-
ELECTRICAL WORKER FROM DEBT
COLLECTOR CAN I SUPPORTED BUT.
AT NINE ONE FIFTY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSON WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. AND NINE ONE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANTONIO SANCHEZ
SOMEWHAT IDW LOCAL ELEVEN LOS
ANGELES. ME AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ BUT
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE TWO OH
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON GRETCHEN NEWSOME ON
BEHALF OF IP W. FIVE SIX NINE
IN OUR THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED
UNITED SELECT YOUR XIN SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
AND GO TO TRAIN WORK FOR EASY
IGP. CERTIFICATION THANK YOU.
AND MY- THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD I. HARD
TO KNOW WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND QUIRK.
FIND THREE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI FOR
LAUREN COLUMN WAS HERE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIANS FOR THIS BILL.
LINE THREE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CHAIRMAN OF A OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- JOHN
DORY IBEW LOCAL SIX IN SAN
FRANCISCO ON BEHALF OF OUR
THREE THOUSAND PLUS MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WE URGE- PASSING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE CHAIR IN
SENATORS- THIS IS WRAPPED IN A
SMALL LEAVING BENICIA
CALIFORNIA I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION IN SUPPORT OF AB A FORTY
ONE THANK YOU. I THREE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHAIR NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
WOULD ADEQUATE WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENTING ACTION CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. NINE THREE TWENTY
FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BRED VERO AT THE
NATIONAL ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND RIVER THEY IN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE THE PLUMBING AND
PIPING INDUSTRY HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF. AB EIGHT FOUR ONE
THANK YOU. LINE THREE OH TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS WILL SMITH'S
IBEW LOCAL THREE THREE TWO
SANTA CLARA COUNTY REPRESENT
OVER THIRTY SIX HUNDRED MEN
MEMBERS AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT FOUR ONE AS WELL AS A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
BUT THE V. I. T. P.
CERTIFICATION. THANK YOU. AND
MINE THREE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TO COMMITTEE
JEREMY LET YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT.
AND MY ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JOSEPH
SULLIVAN. I REPRESENT THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATION
COMMITTEE OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES THIS REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS. IN PLOY
A PROXIMATE LEE EIGHT THOUSAND.
UNION LECTURE XIN C<c.cyan> I</c>
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHT FORTY
ONE AS WELL AS THE E. D. I. T.
P. REQUIREMENT FOR QUALITY AND
SAFETY THANK YOU. AND NINE
THREE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
EVERYONE A ON WITH BRIGHT LINE
DIFFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND NINE THREE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I HAD. MY NAME OF
EGBERT BUT LOCAL THREE FORTY
THREE UP ON A LISTING VOTERS
ARE NAPA SOLANO COUNTY AND WE
ARE DURING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN THEIR SPORT. THANK
YOU. IN NINE THREE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTER HERE
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BOB
STOKER AND ON BEHALF OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR
WHICH ENCOMPASSES FORTY NINE A
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE AND IT'S
EVIDENCE BASED OBJECTIVES THE
BOTH INVESTING CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU.
AND NINE THREE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND THE APPLE- BESTEST AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NINE ONE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MIKE MENDOZA I AM ELECTRICIANS.
AND I SUPPORT THE EEVEE ITP
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL. IN
NINE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MIKE TALKING WITH IBEW
LOCAL LEVEL OUT THERE YOU LOOK
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER THE
D. V. I. P. B. REQUIREMENT
BILL. THANK YOU. AND NINE THREE
FIFTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISS CHAIR YOU COMMITTEE THIS
IS CHRIS WALKER I'LL BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SHEET
METAL AIR CONDITIONING
CONTRACTORS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE V. EIGHT FORTY
ONE AND JUST ASK THANK YOU. AND
NINE THREE ZERO NINE. YOUR MIND
OPEN. SIX GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
ZERO NINE YOU MAY BE A NEW CALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CHRIS CENTER AND I'M ELECTRICAL
WORKER. AND I SUPPORT THE EBT I
TP REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL. IN
MINE TWO TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MARK ROGERS I'M A
CONTRACTOR WORKING FOR BAKER
ELECTRIC AND I SUPPORT DVI D.
B. REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL
THANK YOU. NINE THREE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
NANCY CHINA AS A SPIN OFF ON
BEHALF OF SCHOOL ENERGY.
COALITION RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I HAVE A THE EIGHT POINT
ONE THANK YOU. AND. NINE THREE
TWO ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL CALLS.
WILL FALL IT WILL BE OPEN FOR
ALL OF ON US NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED VENDORS PLUS IN SUPPORT
OF THE EIGHT FORTY ONE A. LIKE.
KLAY ALL. THE IN MIND ONE THIRD.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE THIRTY YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DAVID WHAT CARL I'M A
PROJECT MANAGER WITH A
COLLECTOR. AND I WILL GIVE YOU
A FEW KEY REQUIREMENTS THE BILL.
IN LINE AT ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE FORTY FIVE YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE TWO
SIXTY. NINE TO SIXTY. YOUR LINE
IS OPENPLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RJ FERRARI
LOCAL THIRTY EIGHT THE DISTRESS
SAMPLES GO I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AB EIGHT FORTY ONE. AND NINE
ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS MY
NAME IS JASON IN THE TELCO I'M
A CALIFORNIA STATE CERTIFIED
GENERAL ELECTRICITY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY I SUPPORT B. B. I. T.
PAY REQUIREMENTS AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU. AND NINE TO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CHRIS CHAVEZ I'M THE THAT THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR CCA IS PLEASED TO
STAND SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE. AND NINE THREE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MY NAME IS JOHN KERRY. SEND THE
MEN AND WOMEN OF I'D BE DEBT
THE SIX THIRTY NINE IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. IN LINE ONE EIGHTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS AMERICA IS GO
AHEAD. CHARACTER MATTERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIN
TELETHON A LEXICAL WORKER AND
I'M USED ON THE BOARD OF THE
EASY I REQUIREMENTS THE BILL.
NINE ONE TWO YEARS IS A PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ELIMINATED KERN ILL I
AM THE PROJECT ENGINEER BAKER
ELECTRIC CORPORATION AND I
SUPPORT EVEY I. T. PEOPLE
CARMEN THE BILL THANK YOU. IN
MINE THREE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS BRIAN HOLD
REPRESENTING IBEW LOCAL FOUR TO
EIGHTY KERN COUNTY. AND WE
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE WITH THE
SKILLED TRAINED IN THE V. I. P.
FEATURED APART WORKFORCE. AT
NINE THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS NICOLE ISOLA AND
I'M A CALIFORNIA STATE
CERTIFIED GENERAL LIKE
CHRISTIAN. AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE E. V. I. T. T.
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL
THANKS. AND LINE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS A BEEN
COUPLES ELECT AND
REPRESENTATIVES FOR IDW TO
THIRTY FOUR MONTEREY BAY AND
COVERING THE TRI COUNTY AREA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND NINE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS STEVEN
BOOKER I'M A BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL SIX
SEVENTEEN IN SEMINOLE COUNTY WE
REPRESENT OVER SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED ELECTRICAL WORKERS. ONE
OF THE ALL THE COMIC BALLERS AN
ERROR TRAINED TECHNICIANS WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE THREE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME CALLING
CONFIRM AND I'M A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS REPRESENTING
ALL CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE A. B.
EIGHT FORTY ONE THANK YOU. AND
NINE TWO SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING IT IS A SHAME BOSTON
BUSINESS MATTER PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR EIGHT
FOUR WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
AFTERNOON SURE HONORABLE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BOB TAYLOR
I'M BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE. BY
LOCAL FOUR FOUR SEVEN. UNDER
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORTER AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE THANK YOU. AT
NINE ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALEC PLANTS BURKE
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY DIRECTOR
WITH THE CAMPER COLLECTIBLE
DESTRUCTION INDUSTRY CALLING IN
WORK EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY ONE AND
IN PARTICULAR THE SKILLED-
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS. THEY
COME WITH. HE TRAINING PROGRAM
THANK. AND MINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS NATALIE HIGLEY I
REPRESENT THE OVER ONE THOUSAND
MEN AND WOMEN OF IDW Y FIVE
ONE IN OUR BUSINESS MANAGER JON
MCINTIRE. WE CAN FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR ONE AM EASY I PP
REQUIREMENTS THE ELECTRICAL
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE TRAINING
PROGRAM CERTIFICATION IS
CRUCIAL TO THIS BUILDING
TRAINED WORKFORCE CENTRAL TO
THE PROCESS OF THESE
IMPROVEMENTS THE BILL THEN
PASSED IN OUR FUTURE IN A
CRUCIAL STEP TOWARD ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROTECTING OUR
CHILDREN AND THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU THOUGH YEAH ON THE
BUILDING. THANK YOU. AND. NINE
ONE NINETY SIX. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND SHARE MY
NAME'S BEYOND MAYES ASSISTANT
TRAINING DIRECTOR WORKING FOR
THE ELECTRICAL TRAINING IS TO
CALIFORNIA ALL OR- NEARLY
TWENTY YEAR MEMBER OF IBEW
LOCAL LEVIN AND LOS ANGELES AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE V. I. T.
RECORD IN THIS BILL. THANK YOU
IN NINETEEN FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FRED LEANING ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS OF PLUMBERS AND STEAM
FITTERS LOCAL UNION NUMBER
THREE FORTY THREE. IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
AND NINE ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS BILL BAKER I'M WITH
IBEW LOCAL FOUR THIRTEEN AND WE
SUPPORT AB EIGHT FORTY ONE.
NINE ONE NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ABRAHAM ALA CARTE. ON THE
STATE SIR PART GENERAL LECTURES
IN CALIFORNIA TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
ONE THANK YOU. NINE THREE
NINETEEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
OF ALL THE TERRORISM
REPRESENTATIVE OF IBEW LOCAL
TWO THIRTY FOUR MODERATE
BENNETT SEVENTY- COUNTY AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE WITH THE FILM
TRAINED WORKFORCE IN THE V. I.
P. E. D. I. T. P. THIRD PARTIES
REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FIFTY NINE. THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
CHRIS MAN FOR THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATION
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL A FORTY ONE. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME CA
HAMILTON ON THAT LETTER CALLED
SOLAR SAFETY TRAINER FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS FIREFIGHTERS POLICE
OFFICERS AND PARAMEDICS FOR THE
FIGHT HE GAZED LLC AND CJ
SELECTABLE SAFETY AND COMPANY
AT FIVE ONE KEEP YOU NONPROFIT
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE AND THE- EVEY
I. T. P. REQUIREMENTS. THANK
YOU. THE MIND THREE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS GUARD NATION ON A
MEMBER OF LOCAL SIX AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- CD I. P.
P. AND THE- BILL OF AB FOR. OUR
EIGHT FOUR ONE. THANK YOU. AT
NINE TO SIXTY FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
STILL TICKET BUSINESS AGENT
WITH IBEW LOCAL ONE EIGHTY
REPRESENTING NAPA AND SOLANO
COUNTY AND WE SUPPORT THE D. V.
I. T. P. REQUIREMENTS IN BILL
AB EIGHT FORTY ONE. THANK YOU.
IN LINE ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
BY NAME AS OUR- HAMPTON I'M A
CALIFORNIA STATE CERTIFIED
GENERAL ATTRITION BUT ID W.
LOOK FINE ART BY AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE D. V. I. T. P.
REQUIREMENT IN THIS BILL. IN
MIND ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN AND HELLO MY NAME IS
BRETT BEARD ON THE EEVEE
INFRASTRUCTURE OPERATIONS
DIRECTORATE ELECTRIC AND WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THE EASY I. T. P.
REQUIREMENTS BILL AND EIGHTY.
IN BILL EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. AND LINE ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHN HENRY LOPEZ I'M WITH THE
U. A LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX
PALMER'S PIPEFITTERS AN HVAC
TECHNICIAN REPRESENTING FRESNO
TO LARRY KING THE MADERA
COUNTY- WE AND WE SPANISH TRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. AND NINE TO FORTY
TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS SANTA
TELL WITH THE BLUE GREEN
ALLIANCE WE REPRESENT THIRTEEN
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
AND UNIONS WHICH STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB EIGHT TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU. AND NINE ONE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY NINE
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS BARBARA MCLAREN I AM LABOR
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION YEAH AND
I SUPPORT THE E. P. I. T. P.
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL THANK
YOU. WHEN ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME MISSION
MARI DAVIS ON THE ELECTRICAL
WORKER WITH IBEW LOCAL ELEVEN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT THE V. I. T. P.
TRAINING IN AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY MY NAME IS MY NAME IS
MARK BOOK ON A STATE CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIAN I WORK FOR RED TOP
ELECTRIC. CORD THE EVEY I. P.
P. REQUIREMENT IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU. AND LINE THREE FIFTY
FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD MY NAME IS JOHN MCVAY I'M
A LECTURE XIN OUT OF LOCAL SIX-
WORK YOU KNOW A LECTURE CAN I
STAND SUPPORT FOR THE V. I. T.
P. REQUIREMENTS THE BILL THANK
YOU. AT NINE TO SEVENTEEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WILLIAM KNACK IN A CONSULTANT
TO THE SAN MATEO COUNTY IDW
NIKA LABOR MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE V.
I. T. P. REQUIRE EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY ONE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COMMENT. AND
NINE ONE THIRTY NINE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS LISA THOUGHT THEY KNOW
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE EVEY
I. T. REQUIREMENTS- I MIDDLE
PEOPLE WORKER AND I IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS UP MY NAME IS BRIAN
GREGORY I'M A TRUSTEE FOR THE
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY ELECTRICAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. WE
SUPPORT AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
BECAUSE IT'LL CREATE TRAINING
AND WORK OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
PURPOSES AS WE UTILIZE THE VERY
EFFECTIVE D. V. I. T. P.
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM. TO ENSURE THIS
INSTALLATIONS POSSIBLE I THINK.
IN NINE THREE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MISTER CHAIR IN THE- MR. IN THE
HE CHECKED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SO MUCH TIME ON A JUST
THINKING WHO STILL ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT. WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THAT THE- MAYBE SUBMIT
THEIR COMMENTS IN WRITING TO
THE COMMITTEE. WHICH I'M SURE
YOU GLADLY ACCEPT AND JUST TO
RESPECTFULLY BE ABLE TO MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IF THE- CHAIR IS SO
INCLINED. IT IS IT'S A AT THAT
OKAY WITH THE CHAIR OF YES YES
YOU. OKAY SO SEN. WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO KEEP GOING YES
PLEASE GO TO OUR OKAY THANK YOU
TEN POINT THREE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
BOBBY STEPS WHEN REPRESENT SIX.
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN
STANISLAUS WERE SAD- BUT
EMPLOYMENT COUNTY. AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. PLEASE CONTINUE.
PLEASE CONTINUE BUT WHAT THE
SPEAKER TO SUPPORT. WHAT'S THE
HOLD. DO WE HAVE ARE WE DONE
WITH THE SPEAKERS. I THOUGHT WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN LEFT IN THE
QUEUE OKAY COULD YOU PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU NINE TO
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED HONORABLE MEMBERS MONEY
IN THE POT HE ALSO ON THE
BUSINESS MANAGER VIEW A LOCAL
OR SEVEN PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS REPRESENT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED WORKING MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND I AM CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU. AND NINE
TO SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MERRIMENT AND I KNOW
LIKE TO WORK AT A LOCAL SIX I
WORK FOR AFTER ELECTRIC AND ACT
ACCORDINGLY ET ITP REQUIREMENT
IN THE BILL THANK YOU. IN
NINETEEN FORTY ONE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS A BUCKLEY ANALYTICAL
WORK BETTER IBEW LOCAL TECH
CENTER JUST GO. WITH THE EASY
ITP PARTED ABA FORTY ONE THANK
YOU. AT NINE TO SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
BARBER I'M AT TRAINING DIRECTOR
AND I WORK FOR THE SAN MATTEO
COUNTY ELECTRICAL JTC AND I
SUPPORT THE EASY G. P.
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NINE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR HONOR MY NAME IS
RANDY STEVENS AND I'M A PROJECT
DEVELOPER FOR THE ELECTRIC
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY OF
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL EASY IDPS
REQUIREMENTS. AND NINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MICHELLE
I'M VERY HAPPY TO IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT TWENTY ONE. IN MINOR
THREE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS HUNTER STERN WITH IBEW
LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE. IN LINE THREE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JASON ASHMAN BUSINESS MANAGER
OF IBEW LOCAL FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
SALMON TO DO YOU KNOW ANYONE
MONO COUNTY AND I SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT FORTY ONE AND SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORK WITH THE EASY I T.
P. SORT OF THE THANK YOU. AT
NINE THIRTY. IT IS A PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S BETHANY
PHILLIP BAUMAN ELECTRICAL
WORKER I WORK FOR CUPERTINO
ELECTRIC AND I SUPPORT THE
EEVEE ATP REQUIREMENTS AND THE
BILL THANK YOU. IN LINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JEREMY FACT THE
PRODUCT MANAGER WITH OUR
MENTALITY CONSULTING SUPPORT
EVEY I KEEP THE REQUIREMENTS
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND MY
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
MITCH KLEIN ON THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE V. EIGHT
FORTY ONE AND ALSO EVEY I. T.
B. REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND NINE THREE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ERIC CARLE
HER GETTING GREEN NOT PROVIDER
IN THE FUTURE DOCTOR INSERTED
AND BROAD SUPPORT THE CURRENT
VERSION OF AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. NEXT BAKER. THE LINE
IS OPEN NINE THREE SIXTY TWO.
AT NINE THREE SIXTY TWO YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE FIFTY
THREE. NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND ALL
THE MEMBERS THIS IS TOM A
BUSINESS AGENT PERFORMERS AND
PIPEFITTERS U. A LOCAL HOLE FOR
SEVEN AND I AM CALLING IN DAY
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
NINE THREE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR HUESO AND SENATORS NATE
THURMOND BUSINESS MANAGER OF
IBEW LOCAL FOUR SIXTY FIVE AND
I CALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO NAY NINE
TWO FIFTY FIVE. NINE TWO FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS
JOHN CORSO CLIMBERS INSTANT
BETTER SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA- CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPLY PORT
OF WITNESSES. ON AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE FOR AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
PLEASE- CHECK ONE MORE TIME.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO. SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MINE THREE SEVENTY NINE.
YOUR MIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ALICE KESSLER
ON BEHALF OF THE. AND NINE ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MY
NAME IS RICK BULIMIA AND I
DON'T REMEMBER THE PIN THE TAIL
CITY COUNCIL AND A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS THAT
COME INTO CLEAN ENERGY STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE V. I. T. P.
TRAINING AND I HEARD SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. EIGHT FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. AND MINE THREE SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JAMES BRADLEY
I'M AN ELECTRICAL WORKER IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S. YOU LOCAL SECTION
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL
AS IT'S WRITTEN AND I
ESPECIALLY SUPPORT THE HE- T.
P. TRAINING. IN LINE THREE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HI ONE
FRESNO STATE CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIANS WITH IBEW LOCAL
FIVE NINE FIVE I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE V. I. P. P.
REQUIREMENTS FOR THIS BILL. IN
LINE TO NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CAPTAIN GOMEZ AND I AM
WORKING FOR LABOR MANAGEMENT
CORPORATION MY COLLEAGUES IN
COURT THAT HE BE I. T. P.
REQUIREMENTS IT IS THE BEST
THING TO KEEP THIS WORK STATE.
AND I FULLY SUPPORT AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE. HAVING HER FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM. ANY
OPPOSITION AND WE'LL GO TO. THE
LEAD- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH MARK TONY FROM
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
MISTER TONY UNDERSTAND HE'S
ONLINE. IS ARE YOU ON THE LINE
MISTER TONY. SMART TONY ON THE
LINE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. IF
HE'S NOT IMMEDIATELY READY IS
COREY BONELESS ON THE LINE.
MIKE TONI IS ON THE LINE VERY
WELL- MISTER TONY PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR COMMENTS. YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE MISTER SIGN. GET
OUT GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS IT
NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
TURN I'M STEPPING MARK TONY TO
DROP OFF THE CALL FOR BOB MY
APOLOGIES. BUT YOUR CHAIR THAT
IS FINE MEMBERS ARE NOT TURN ON
BEHALF. ON BEHALF OF TURN WE DO
HAVE AN OPPOSE DIVISION ONAB
EIGHT FORTY ONE- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING- SO LET ME LOOK
JUST TAKE. OF THAT IS. HE BOBBI
IS PRESENT I COULD JUST
INTERRUPT YOU HE BEGAN IS
PRETTY PRESENTATION ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. OKAY
I APPRECIATE THAT A LOT OF BY
MY COMMENTS- MORE CONCERNED
PRIMARILY. WAS ACTING BILL AS
DRAFTED. WOULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
COMING FROM RIGHT THERE'S A
LITTLE ACCOUNTABILITY AT A TIME
WHEN REALLY RATE CARES CAN'T
AFFORD IT- ARE CONCERNED THAT
THERE THAT THERE WERE PENDING
PROCEEDINGS THAT NEEDED TO BE
DEALT WITHOUT THE CPUC AND NOT.
OVERRIDE THAT PROCESS TO
DICTATE THE OUTCOME IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD. REMOVE THOSE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WHICH
THOSE OF BILL THAT COULD IN
FACT CHANGE THE POSITION OF TAR
SO I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THOSE AMENDMENTS IN
PRINT- BUT WE WOULD SAY THAT IF
IT DOES NOT CHANGE THAT OR WE
FEEL FOR K. WE WANT. ENSURE
THAT WE PART THE COMMISSION
PROCESS. SO THAT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS CAN PARTICIPATE IN
THEIR OUTCOMES THAT'LL
DETERMINE YOUR COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS AS OPPOSED TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT IN THEFUTURE
IF THERE ARE HEAVILY DEBATED.
ITEMS THAT THE COMMISSION WE
WOULD NOT WANT SOMEONE COMING
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO OVERRIDE
THE COMMISSION- WHEN SOMETHING
IS IN THE PROCESS. AND EVEN AS
THE BILL AS DRAFTED THERE IS AN
APPLICATION THAT WOULD BE
APPROVED. BEFORE HIT IT HAS
EVEN BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMISSION SO WE WILL LOOK AT
THOSE AMENDMENTS VERY CLOSELY
WE DO APPRECIATE AND LIKE THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED. BY THE
CANADIAN DOLLAR SYSTEM BY THE
COMMITTEE SO WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT MISTER CHAIR I WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO LOOKING AT THOSE
AMENDMENTS WHILE THEY'RE- AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION BASED ON THE- AND TO
BE FAIR TO YOU. SIR I'D LIKE TO
READ THE AMENDMENT OTHER THERE
QUITE MOUTHFUL. BUT IF IT'S
OKAY WITH YOU I'M GONNA READ
THEM. AND THIS WOULD BE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL THE SPEAKERS AT
WILL BE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE. THIS MIGHT
REMOVE SOME OPPOSITION ARE THIS
MIGHT CREATE SOME BUT- I WANTED
TO FOR THE YEAR BENEFIT AND IF-
I'LL RESERVE. A FEW MORE. MAYBE
ANOTHER MINUTE FOR YOU TO
COMMENT ON WHAT I'M ABOUT TO
READ IT MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH.
FOR YOU TO FULLY UNDERSTAND BUT
YOU MIGHT- SO I JUST WANT TO
READ THEM TO YOU. BECAUSE THESE
ARE ARE. THESE AMENDMENTS WERE-
WERE PREPARED OVER THE WEEKEND
AND I KNOW THIS PROCESS IS VERY
DIFFICULT. AND HARD FOR PEOPLE
TO- WAY AND UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT- I WILL READ
THE AMENDMENTS NOW THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. TO DRESS THE SPEED
OF RESOLVING THE PENDING
APPLICATIONS. THIS BILL TO
REQUIRE THE CPUC. THERESA THE
TO PAY APPLICATIONS BY THE DATE
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL MARCH
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
AFFORD THE CPU SO. THE ABILITY
TO PROVE MODIFY TONIGHT THE
APPLICATION. THE SECOND
AMENDMENT. IS IN WHICH IS BILL
FOR ST REFERENCE IN THE FUTURE.
NOT FILED. APPLICATION AND IT-
IN PARENTHESES PGA ANY
APPLICATION. THE THIRD
AMENDMENT IS TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
TRACKING OF COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH TV CHARGING APPLICATIONS.
NUMBER ONE DIRECT THE CPC TO
REQUIRE SUFFICIENT TRACKING AND
REPORTING OF TOTAL COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS. AND TO ALLOW THE
CPU CEDAR JUSTICE POLICY
WITHOUT THE NEED. FOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION. ONLY AFTER
THE UTILITY HAS IMPLEMENTED
THIS POLICY WITHIN A GENERAL
RATE CASE CYCLE. NUMBER FOUR
AMENDMENT IS DELETE LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE CVC TWO PROGRAMS
IN THE ABSENCE OF PROGRAMMER
GALATIANS OUR GUIDELINES AND
INSTEAD. REQUIRE THE CVC TO
PROVE GRANTS UPON ADOPTION OF
PROGRAM REGULATIONS AND
GUIDELINES. THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
AMENDMENT NUMBER FIVE REQUIRE
THE CVC TO NOTIFY APPROPRIATE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE. THAT A
DIVERSE GROUP OF QUALIFIED
CRIME CONTRACTORS ARE AWARE OF
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AMENDMENT
NUMBER SIX CLARIFY THAT FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS FOR THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIED TO ENERGY INFILL. I'LL
REPEAT CLARIFY THAT FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS FOR THIS BILL ONLY
APPLY TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY
INCENTIVES FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE PROGRAM YEARS AND
AUTHORIZES CVC TO SET
APPLICATION IN INCOME BIRDS
DEADLINES TO ENSURE THAT ALL
WORK INITIATE UNDER UNDER THE
PROGRAM WILL BE COMPLETED BY
APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SO I WILL GO BACK. TO A- OF
MISTER. QUINN'S ALL THIS IS
THAT I'M SORRY. FOR WAS MISTER
HERNANDEZ SORRY IGNAZ ISN'T IT
NICE YOU YEAH OKAY THE
NECESSARY STILL THERE. IT I'M
I'M HERE MISTER CHAIR. DID YOU
WANNA VERY MUCH APPROPRIATE FOR
YOU TO. YEAH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR RUNNING THROUGH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT I WAS
TAKING NOTES ON IT- I CAN'T SAY
THAT EVERY MOVES ARE OPPOSITION
AT THIS MOMENT BUT WE WORLD-
MAKE A GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO
REEVALUATE OUR POSITION AND WE
WILL BE LOOKING AT THE-
IMMEDIATELY IN GOING THROUGH
THEM. IT DOESN'T ARE AT LEAST
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS THERE MAY
BE SOME NUANCES WE MAY STILL
HAPPEN COMMENT. IF CAN'T STAY
AT THE BACK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY
WILL MOVE NOW TO COREY BOLAS
WITH THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
COALITION ASSOCIATION IS A
MISTER BULLISH ON THE LINE.
WELL HE'S HERE IN THE CALORIE
OKAY MISTER BLISS WELCOME. YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CORBELS ON BEHALF OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS COMPRISED
OF TWELVE COMPANIES IN THE
EEVEE CHARGING INDUSTRY. WE ARE
REGRETFULLY OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT
FOUR ONE BECAUSE OF THE E. D.
I. T. P. CERTIFICATION MANDATE
AS IT AS IT HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO SLOW CHARGING STATION
DEPLOYMENT WITHOUT PROVIDING A
CLEAR SAFETY BENEFITS. WE DON'T
TAKETHIS OPPOSITION LIGHTLY AS
WE RECOGNIZE MISTER TING AS A
LEADER IN CLEAN ENERGY POLICY.
HOWEVER REQUIRING EVEY A. T. P.
CERTIFICATION- TO ACCESS THESE
CHARGING STATION INCENTIVES
DOESN'T PROVIDE A SAFETY
BENEFIT ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT
THE STATE. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRING. THE PC AND THE C. E.
C. OR D. REQUIRE- PEOPLE TO
HAVE A SEAT TEN- ELECTRICIANS
LICENSE. WHICH IS RIGOROUS TO
OBTAIN AN RECALL AND ENTAILS
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF. ON THE
JOB EXPERIENCE THESE LICENSES
TOGETHER WITH PRODUCT
CERTIFICATION AND LOCAL
BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENTS OR
MORE THAN SUFFICIENT TO ENSURE
ELECTRIC SHINS OR INSTALLING
EVEN CHARGING STATIONS SAY FOR
YOU AND TO RESPOND TO ONE OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
WHILE THE PC DOES HAVE THIS AS
PART OF ITS SAFETY CHECKLIST IT
HAS NOT MANDATED THIS AS PART
OF. ALL EVEY CHARGING STATION
PROJECTS FOR APPLICATIONS AND
EVEN IN ONE CASE DECIDED TO
DECLINE ADOPTING THIS
REQUIREMENT FOR ONE OF THE TV
CHARGING STATION PROJECTS. HAS
WRITTEN THIS PROVISION WOULD
CUT OUT VIABLE CHARGING
PROJECTS AND IN THE SHORT TERM
RESTRICT THE LABOR POOL AND
DRIVE UP COSTS AS THE INDUSTRY
GRAPPLES WITH RECESSION.
FURTHERMORE THIS GIVES YOU THE
I. T. P. MONOPOLY ON TRAINING
CURRICULUM. AT FOR CHARGING
INSTALLATION WITH NO OVERSIGHT
FROM THE STATE ON CURRICULUM
COSTS FOR THE ABILITY TO ENSURE
THERE'S ENOUGH TRAINING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE. FOR AN
INFLUX OF WHAT WILL BE
THOUSANDS OF ELECTRICIANS
LOOKING TO GET THE
CERTIFICATION. CALIFORNIA ONLY
HAS FORTY CERTIFIED TRAINERS
CURRENTLY LOCATED MOSTLY IN
COASTAL URBAN AREAS AND AS LATE
AS LAST YEAR WITH NINE NORTH OF
SACRAMENTO. AS RECOMMENDED BY
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS GIVEN
THAT THE PC AND THE CDC OR
ALREADY IN THE PROCESS PROCESS
OF CONSIDERING REQUIRING THE V.
I. T. P. THOSE PROCESS HE
SHOULD PLAY OUT WERE EVEY ATP
CAN BE VETTED MORE THOROUGHLY.
THANK YOU. VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WILL MOVE TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND COLD THE- OR OR
INSTRUCT THE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO- Q. IN LINE.
ABSOLUTELY IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE THREE ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AS OUTLINED IN THE
WATER. THANK YOU FOR TAX. ARE
IN LINE TO FORTY IN LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
EVENING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS CARL LONDON SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF ELECTRIFY AMERICA WE-
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE UNLESS
AMENDED AND ASSOCIATE OURSELVES
WITH UBC'S COMMENTS WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT SUCH A
REQUIREMENT COULD BE CONSTRUED
TO MAKE THIS REQUIREMENT
APPLICABLE TO ALREADY APPROVED
PROJECTS ARE AGREEMENTS
INCLUDING THE ONE UNDER WHICH-
THE STATE IN OUR CLIENT WORK
TODAY. WE DON'T BELIEVE IT
CAN'T BELIEVE ASKS FOR CLARITY
ON THIS POINT WE SUPPORT
COMMITTEE STAFFS IN KOREAN MEN
ELSE'S ON THIS VERY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IN LINE EIGHTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
NEED A LONGER PRESENTED THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL.
WE HAVEN'T UPLOADED LIKE THE
MENDED POSITION AND TAKE IT OUT
ONE LETTER THANK YOU. AND NINE
THREE ZERO FOR. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS IS A CHARITY
HERE THE CALIFORNIA WE GET THE
PRODUCERS REPRESENTING THE
PROCESSORS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NEXT BECOME MINE.
ONE THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR KERRY MEMBERS THIS
OF BASS ALONSO. GEN THE LAST
MAN AND WITH OUR AMENDMENT
OUTLINED IN OUR LETTERS THANK
YOU. AND NINE THREE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
DOCTOR HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LARGE INTERVIEW
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION OF THE-
WE ALSO HAVE A- LOOK AT THE
DECISION ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND NINE THREE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
THREE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LIKE THREE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO LIVING
UP IN THERE YOU GO ELECTRICAL
WORKER YEAH I WORK FOR BREYER
ELECTRIC AND I BUT AB AT PURE
CRIME IN THE BILL. THANK YOU.
IN LINE THREE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ATTY
MOUNTAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION
AND WE WITH A LINE ARE
OPPOSITION WITH AND THE LETTERS
COMMITTED BY AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS THE ASIAN AND
OTHERS. MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN I'M SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
IT IT HAD THREE IN Q. AND IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHT FORTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN IT SPEAKING IN.
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN%
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE TO
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY THREE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE VAL
KILMER DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY FOR CHARGE POINTS OUT WE
RESPECTFULLY TECHNICAL GLICKMAN
SESSION IN LINE WITH THE
COMMENT GIVEN BY THE LEGAL
CHARGES THE PATIENT AND ABOUT
ONE IN OUR LETTER. THANK YOU.
IN MIND THREE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS RICHARD MARX AND
FOR THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FOUR THOUSAND
APPRENTICES AND ELECTRICAL
TRAINEES IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO SECTION THREE THE
IN THE I. T. P. MANDATE THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN Q. WELL WE WILL-
COME TO. THE COMMITTEE NOW FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OR MOTION.
FIRST OF ALL WE WILL INTERNET
ENTERTAIN ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BEFORE MOTIONS SO
PLEASE- WHO HAS A COMMENT OR
QUESTION. OKAY WE'LL START WITH
CENTER HERTZBERG AND SENATOR
MORE LOCKED AND CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AGAIN I WANT TO STRESS THE SAME
POINT THAT WE HAVE IN MISTER
TING HERE WITH AS THE AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE THIS IS PART OF A
LARGER ARCHITECTURE OF
DISCUSSION. TO GET PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK. FOR THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PLAN THAT THE BILL BE
YOU'LL STILL SEE SOME FURTHER
AMENDMENTS I WOULD SUSPECT IS
IN ALL OF THESE MEASURES. AS
THE PACKAGES COME TOGETHER.
BETWEEN THE WE'VE ALREADY HAVE
THIS IS PART OF A TO US DEAL
YOU WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR BUT-
IN ANY EVENT I WANTED MEMBERS
TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS PART OF
THE LARGER FRAMEWORK OF WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR
THE LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS. ASK
YOU SUPPORT. VERY WELL CENTER
MORE LUCK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND REVIEWING THIS BILL
WHICH IS RATHER COMPLEX AND HAS
ARTS TWO MAJOR COMPONENTS- IT
JUST SEEMS AS IF THE CPUC
FAILED AND PROVIDING ADEQUATE
SUPERVISION FOR A REBATE
PROGRAM AND- I JUST BELIEVE
THIS MIGHT BE THE WRONG
SOLUTION BECAUSE IT DOES AND
WILL INCREASE RATES FOR ALL
TAXPAYERS AND WE ARE. GOING TO
BE HURTING THE POOR IT'S A
REGRESSIVE. OPPRESSIVE
REQUIREMENTS ON ON THOSE THAT
CAN AFFORD IT THE LEAST IT'S A
BIGGER PORTION OF THEIR OVERALL
PERSONAL BUDGET SIDE I HOPE AS
WE LOOK FOR WAYS TO IMPROVE THE
ECONOMY WERE NOT TONE DEAF ON
WHO'S GONNA BE UNDERWRITING OF
THESE EFFORTS- WE ARE IN AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND I'LL BE
OPPOSED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU CENTER MORE LOG.
CENTER BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHILL AND- I STAND HERE.
CAUTIOUSLY SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE TODAY ARE NOT EXPRESSED
SOME MY SAME CONCERNS THAT I
DID WHEN I WAS IN ASSEMBLY WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN NEGOTIATED THE
CELL SETTLEMENT WITH ENERGY
AFTER THE ENERGY CRISIS WITH
THE INSTALLATION OF CHARGING
STATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND MY CONCERN
VAN AS IT IS NOW THAT VERY FEW
IF ANY MINORITY CONTRACTORS GOT
ANY OF THIS WORK. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY NONE OF THESE
CHARGING STATIONS WANTED TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THE
MAJORITY OF THEM WENT INTO SAN
DIEGO SACRAMENTO LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO PHIL INDIANA
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE. WORKING PEOPLE TO GO
TO ELECTRICAL VEHICLES WE MUST
PROVIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
CHARGE THESE VEHICLES I'M !NG
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENT THAT
SPEAKS TO ONE I THE GERMANS
LEADERSHIP AND- ASKING FOR
DIVERSE CONTRACTORS SHOULD BE
ADDED BUT I THINK THE LANGUAGE
COULD BE. STRENGTHENED TO BE AS
IT DOESN'T FALL UNDER GENERAL
ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX LIKE A
UTILITY. THOUGHT I WOULD ASK
THAT. WE NOT JUST GIVE
NOTIFICATION TO. MINORITY
CONTRACTORS BUT WE MAKE A
DIRECT EFFORT TO CONTACT THEM
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY MAKE A
DIRECT EFFORT TO USE MINORITY
PRINT AND DIGITAL OUTREACH THE
CONTACT. NOT ONLY CONTRACTORS
BUT A DIVERSE WORKFORCE AS
WELL. AND MY QUESTION RADAR AS
IT RELATES TO THE H. H. BACK.
WITHIN SCHOOLS. ALSO INCLUDES.
ON THE PORTABLE BUILDING
FACILITIES AS WELL. THANK YOU
SIR REFER SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I ALSO LEE-
WANNA CONSCIOUSLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL I HAVE MANY MANY CONCERNS
BUT I WILL START BY AND CLEAN
THE COMMENTS OF THE GREAT
SENATOR FROM GUARDINO AS IT
PERTAINS TO A DIVERSE
CONTRACTORS AND HE ALSO STATED
WHICH I BELIEVE THAT USUALLY
THESE DON'T END UP AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW
WHICH I HAPPEN TO REPRESENT AND
SO. ON THERE'S SO MANY ISSUES
EMBEDDED IN THIS BILL THAT I
USUALLY I'M NOT COMFORTABLE I'M
REALLY THAT THEY SHOULD BE
SEPARATE BILLS WITH SEPARATE
ISSUES- BUT I ALSO JUST HEARD
SENATOR HURTS PERSON JUST.
ABOUT AMENDMENT MEANING
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS AND I
HOPE THAT HE DOES I'M NOT
REALLY HAPPY ABOUT THE C. P.
C.'S LOCK OF RESPONSIVENESS IN
THIS ISSUE AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S ALSO AN ISSUE THAT WE
NEED TO TACKLE I IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THEY DO WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO- AND I'LL JUST.
SAY THAT- I HOPE TO SEE THE
CEMENT BUT I WILL BEGIN
CAUTIOUSLY SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE SOME SURVEYING THE
ROOM- CENTERS SKINNER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE- ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS IT IS A SUNSET
ON THE PORTION THAT WILL USE
THE EFFICIENCY FUNDS FOR
SCHOOLS CORRECT. A REFERENCE
SEEN THE AMENDMENTS YEAH
CONSULTANT IS NOT IT'S AT THE
ONES THAT ARE READ DIRECT. YES
YES- I. IF THIS WERE A
PERMANENT CHANGE HI WOULD
LIKELY NOT BE SUPPORTED EVEN
THOUGH I THINK THE NEED IN OUR
SCHOOLS IS ESSENTIAL BUT I
THINK RIGHT NOW ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE COVERT PANDEMIC. AND
OUR KNOWLEDGE THAT BAD INDOOR
AIR QUALITY BAD CIRCULATION OF
AIR IN IN INDOORS CAN FURTHER
THE PANDEMIC BUT ADDITIONALLY
WE KNOW THAT. IT IS UNHEALTHY
BANDS THAT OUR SCHOOLS
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE FOR WHATEVER
REASON THE- EITHER THE DESIGN
OR THE H. BACK SYSTEMS IN THEM
WHAT HAVE YOU THE INDOOR AIR
QUALITY LEVELS ARE BELOW ARE
FOR ARE NOT. HEALTHY IN OUR
SPEND MOST OF OUR CLASSROOM
AND IT AFFECTS THE STUDENT'S
ABILITY LEARN EFFECT SO MUCH
EFFECTS ANYWAY SO I. GIVEN THAT
INTERESTING WHEN I WAS DRIVING
TO SACRAMENTO I HEARD ON THE
RADIO SOME THAT THAT-
CONSTRUCTION THAT STARTS WERE
DOWN THE NEW CONSTRUCTION JOBS
WERE- DOWN DUE TO PANDEMIC
INDUCED ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. AND
THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
WORK THAT IS. IT NEEDED WILL
BENEFIT ARE SO. COULD HELP
OFFSET SOME OF THAT OTHER
DROPPED IN CONSTRUCTION SO WITH
THAT I THINK IT'S VERY THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT AT BILL IN
VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENTS NOW
ON THE TV PART. I WOULD PREFER
THAT THERE NOT BE A STRICT
REQUIREMENT AROUND THE- P. V.
I. T. P. AND MAYBE THAT'S STILL
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DISCUSSED
BUT I AM. VERY WILLING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL NOW THANK YOU.
VERY WELL ANY OTHER SPEAKERS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL NOW. CENTER HERTZBERG
MOVES THE BILL AND- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE SOMECLOSING COMMENTS JUST
VERY QUICKLY TO MISTER MAJESTIC
PICTURE AND ALL THE SENATORS
FOR THEIR DISCUSSION- I WOULD
DOES ALSO TO ADDRESS THE
SENATORS WORRIED ABOUT
DIVERSITY HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE GREATER DISCUSSION TO
ENSURE THAT ON MY- ON MY CELL
SHARE YOUR CONCERN AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE. THIS GREEN
ECONOMY TEACHES SICK EVERY PART
OF THE STATE NOT JUST SOME
PARTS OF THE STATE SO. ON
THAT'S ALSO ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE- WERE TRYING TO GET THE
P. YOU SEE TO MAKE A DECISION
AGAIN. NONE OF SAY WHAT THE
DECISION SHOULD BE. WE ASK THAT
A DATE CERTAIN BE MADE A
DECISION FOR THESE ARE EVEY
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN
LANGUISHING THERE FOR NUMBER
YEARS NOW. ALSO IN TERMS OF THE
CONCERNS FROM MY GOOD FRIEND TO
TURN AS WELL AS- SENATOR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY REGARDING OUR
REPAIR COSTS. AGAIN THERE IS A
CURRENT PART OF MY THAT IS
SITTING THERE I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAS NOT
BEEN SPENT- THIS IS MONEY THAT
I'VE TRIED TO REPURPOSE IN THE
PAST FOR. A CORNER STORES FOR
DURATION IT'S OUR MONEY IT'S
OUR REPAIR MONEY THAT. HAS
BEEN. WAITING THERE AND-
WAITING FOR THIS TO BE CLAIMED.
IT HASN'T BEEN CLAIMED IT I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU IT'S A
FAILURE UPON THE CPU SEES PART.
TO ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THE RATE
PAYER MONEY GETS BACK TO THE
RATE PAYERS DOESN'T ALONG THE
CPUC ACCOUNTABLE ôNG IN ORDER.
AND SO ALL I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE
HAVE. ABOUT THE PROPOSAL. ON
THE AGAIN WE THINK THIS A GOOD
TIME TO BE USING OUR MONEY. IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS FOR OUR JOBS.
AND HAPPY TO HAVE A DEBATE
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE PROPOSAL
SHOULD BE OUT THERE. BUT I
DON'T THINK IT SHOULD BE
SITTING IN THE CPUC BANK
ACCOUNT. THAT'S WHY I DON'T
THINK. IN THE LASTLY IN TERMS
OF TV. D. V. I. T. P. I'M I'M
IN THIS VERY- WEIRD POSITION OF
HAVING OPPOSITION FROM MY GOOD
FRIENDS IN THE CHARGING
COMMUNITY WERE USUALLY WORKING
VERY VERY CLOSELY. I WOULD JUST
HOPE THAT THE TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THIS PROGRAM IT'S A
IT'S A TWO DAY TRAINING PROGRAM.
IN OFFERED A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AS WELL THAT MANY. MANY
PRESSURE PROGRAMS- WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
OF ADEQUATE TRAINING WHO DO
THIS KIND OF WORK. AND WE THINK
THAT WE DO ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY
TO REALLY. BE UTILIZING THESE
PROGRAMS ALL AROUND THE STATE
AND WITH THAT. TO SPEAK USE
VERY MUCH FOR THE- HARDWARE
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND JUST
RESPECT FOR US RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I JUST WANT TO ADD.
WE HAD AN INCIDENT IN SAN DIEGO
WHERE WE HAD AN UNTRAINED
ELECTRICIAN- THAT WAS INVOLVED
IN BUILDING IN A BUS STOP. AND
BECAUSE THEY THE ELECTRICAL
INSTALLATION IMPROPERLY
SOMEBODY SAT AT THE BUS STATION
ONCE ELECTROCUTED TO DEATH THE
REQUIREMENT THAT YU HAVE FOR
TRAINEES VERY REASONABLE THE
CONSEQUENCES COULD BE DEADLY
ESPECIALLY WILL ELECTRICAL
DEALING WITH ELECTRICAL
EQUIPMENT SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- ADDITION TO
THE BILL AND- I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE GOING TO
BE HANDLED IN. ELECTRICAL
DEVICES THAT WE REALLY HAVE
HIGHLY TRAINED PEOPLE DOING
THAT THIS IS A MATTER OF LIFE
AND DEATH IN MANY INSTANCES SO
THIS IS NOT ONLY A SAFETY BILL
THIS IS A ALSO A BIT BUT DEALS
WITH JOB CREATION MANY OTHER
THINGS AND THIS IS A WONDERFUL
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANKS FOR
MOVING FORWARD. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND NOW UP PAST THE
CLERK TO CALL THE ROLL ON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE. AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. BY WES
SO HI. MOORLACH NO. MOORLACH NO.
BRADFORD OUR- BRADFORD HI
CHIANG. DOLLY NO DARLENE THEM.
DOT HI TODD I. HERTZBERG WHICH
PROVIDE HERTZBERG AYE. KILL NO
HILL NO REQUIRE. RUBIO HI. A
CONFINED AREA RUBIO I. RUBIO I.
SKINNER HI INNER HI. STERN
THANK. STERN I. WIENER FIVE
WIENER I. EIGHT DAYS THREE
MALES TERM. THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BILL THE NEXT BILL WILL BE
PRESENTED BY OUR VERY OWN.
SENATOR BRADFORD THAT- FROM NOW
pTHE GREAT. SENATOR FROM
VIRGINIA THE GREAT SENATOR.
PAUL A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY AUTHOR IS ONE OF THE GARCIA.
WILL BE PRESENTED BY THE GREAT
SENATOR FROM GARDENIA. OKAY.
YEAH I AGREE. THANK YOU MISTER
SHEARER AND MEMBERS AND I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AV SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE
GREAT ASSEMBLYMAN EDUARDO
GARCIA THIS BILL CREATES A BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION TO STUDY AND
REPORT. HOW TO DEVELOP A
LITHIUM INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
GLOBAL DEMAND FOR LITHIUM IS
EXPECTED TO GROW BY A FACTOR OF
TEN IN THE NEXT DECADE. BUT
VIRTUALLY MATTER OF THIS
PRODUCT IS PRODUCED. IN UNITED
STATES AND WE SHOULD ALL BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. THE
SALTON SEA GERALD BERMAN
RESEARCH AREA HOUSE OF
SUFFICIENT LOOK BEYOND DEPOSITS
IF UTILIZE PRODUCTION COULD BE
SUBSTANTIAL. DEVELOPING A
LITHIUM INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
WILL ALSO LIVE ECONOMY IN AREAS
LIKE THE SALTON SEA. THE
LEMONADE SOME OF THE
EXPLOITATION THAT'S HAPPENING
IN FOREIGN COUNTRIES WITH A LOT
OF MINERS MINING FOR THOSE
MATERIALS. KILL BERMAN ENERGY
IS ALSO PART OF A BALANCED LIKE
TRICITY GREER. AND WE'RE LUCKY
THAT CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS
GERALD BOARMAN RESEARCHES CAN
ALSO BE USED TO ATTRACT LITHIUM.
AB SIXTY FIFTY SEVEN WILL MOVE
THE BALL FOR ON THE CAN
PRODUCTIONS IN THIS STATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS TIM KELLY. WITH
IMPERIAL VALLEY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
QUESTIONS BE JOHN WHITE OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR CLEAN ENERGY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE FORWARD TO THE LEADS
THE COMMENT FROM THE LEAD-
SUPPORTER OF THE JOHN WHITE- IN
HIS HERE THANK YOU IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE. PROCEED MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOB QUITE
REPRESENTING THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN- WE SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION WE THINK IT'S A
MODEST BUT IMPORTANT STEP. TO
LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR WHAT
COULD BE A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
FUTURE THE ABILITY TO EXTRACT
LITHIUM FOR THERMAL BRIAN.
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
WIN WIN SO THE CALIFORNIA CAN
CREATE ITS OWN SO BECAUSE OF
HIM THAT WILL BE NEEDED FOR
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
OTHER PURPOSES WHILE ALSO
CREATING ANOTHER REVENUE SOURCE
TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT CHIU
THIRD ENERGY WHICH IS CENTER
BRADFORD MENTIONED. IMPORT PART
OF. BUT US FOR NOT. WE ALSO
HAVE TO KELLY REPRESENT IN
IMPAIR VALLEY CAN TO CORP HE ON
THE- IS MISTER ON THE LINE. I
AM ON THE- WELCOME I AM ON THE-
THANK YOU. WITHIN CALDWELL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION CURRENTLY THE
APPROACH AND PRODUCES OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF CLEAN
CLEAN RELIABLE BASELOAD POWER
TO THE GRID THE FOLLOWING THREE
HUNDRED ON A RESOURCE THERE HAS
POTENTIAL FOR TO DO. FIFTEEN
HUNDRED TO TWO THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF PRODUCTION WITH AN
INVESTMENT OF OVER FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
PRODUCERS PRODUCERS ARE THE
NUMBER ONE TAXPAYER NECRO
COUNTY. RIGHT OVER FIVE HUNDRED
DIRECTOR AND FIFTEEN HUNDRED
AND CLERK JOBS IN A COMMUNITY.
THAT WAS JUST NAMED BY USDA AND
THE PERSISTENT POVERTY COUNTY
AND WITH AN UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
AROUND 30% WITH THE ADDITION OF
LIVING EXTRACTION COLLEGIATE
ENERGY. BUT OFFER CHANGE WILL
DOUBLE IN THE ECONOMIC OUTPUT
WILL TRIPLE IF NOT FULL FULL.
THE INCREASE YOUR TOTAL OUTPUT
IMPERIAL COUNTY WILL PROVIDE
CLEAN GREEN RENEWABLE ENERGY TO
THE GRID AND PROVIDE THE ENERGY
AND FROM ALL PRYING. TO MAKE A
LIVING. POSSIBLE CREATION TO
CLARIFY THE LIVE HERE FROM
MARKET AND OFFER TO SECURE THE
OF TO MAKE A THE TRUTH IN IN
CLUSTER IDENTIFY AS LESBIAN.
THE GREATEST SHOW. IN A
TRACKING INVESTMENT FOR SUCH
LARGE PROJECT IS THERE WELL
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS PLUS FOR
EACH FIFTY MEGAWATT POWER PLANT
AND EXTRACTION FACILITY. THE
FOLLOWING SCENE ON JUNE A MORE
RESEARCH AREA IS. IN AB. FORM
YEAH YEAH. BUT LACKS INVESTMENT
MECHANISM. TO BENEFIT THE I
HAVE THE SALTY NON ARMORY AREA
IN. IN ALL. ON WELCOME NOT IN
IT IN SOME A CHALLENGE OF THE
CALL THE TO PAUSE FROM OTHER
STATES. THE FIRST BENEFITS. BUT
AFTER IN ENERGY NEED. TO POWER
THE EXTRACTION. THE PHARMACY
BECAUSE THERE ARE A GOOD FOR
THE GREATEST OPPORTUNITY FOR
LET. EXTRACTION IS LOCATED. IT
IT THROUGH MULTIPLE STATE AND
FEDERAL REGULATORS. ALTHOUGH
THE PROCESS IS NOT THE PROBLEM
IT'S THE TIME FRAME IT TAKES TO
DO IT. GENERAL ENERGY DOES NOT
BENEFIT FROM THE PRODUCTION TAX
CREDIT BECAUSE IT TAKES MORE
THAN ONE YEAR TO. TO EXPLORE
CONSTRUCT. A GENERAL PLAN. WE
NEED PROGRAMS THAT WILL DO YOU
READ THESE ENDEAVORS EVERY YEAR
FOR ALL ENERGY COMPANY IN THE
PRO CAN USE PLANNING IN THE
EXPANDING AND MOST ARE
EXPLORING THE POSSIBILITIES OF
MINERAL LITHIUM EXTRACTION.
ENERGY GENERATION AND LET THEM
EXTRACTION IS ONLY HALF THE
OPPORTUNITY. IF WE COULD ALSO
TRACTOR SUPPLY CHAIN AND
MANUFACTURE COMPONENTS AND
FINISHED PRODUCTS. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IT WOULD BE TEN FOLD
WE DO CREATE THE MUCH NEEDED
JOBS AND GENERATE THE TAXES
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO RECOVER
FROM THE PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
AND THE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND IMPERIAL VALLEY.
IN VALUE LITHIUM NEEDS AND
WANTS YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE INTO ANYONE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN TWO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. BAND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES NOW WE WILL GO
INTO TESTIMONY LIMITED TO-
COMMENTS REGARDING NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURE AGAIN THIS IS AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES WHO IN
THE CHAMBER I DO NOT SEE ANY IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER THESE AVAIL YOURSELF NO
ONE IS HE WILL WANT TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. OUR THE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FORTY I DON'T SEE
ONE AVAILABLE IN TWENTY FORTY.
NOW WE WILL THE MOVE TO
TELECONFERENCE WILL PARTICIPATE
IN THROUGH THE TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. CREDITOR
WAITING GENTLEMAN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND FIRST ABOUT A
LINE NUMBER TWO NINETY LINE TO
LINE TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE NINETY THREE
MODEM SOCIAL CUTE GIVE ME ONE
MOMENT. TWO NINETY PLEASED TO
BACK UP A PRESSING ONE FOR ONE
AND ZERO. TAXABLE TO LINE
NUMBER THREE NINETY YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THREE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OPERATE ON
THE DEAN- ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NOW MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
TWO NINETY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI I'M NOT SURE FOR I
MEAN BETWEEN THIS JUST LOOK TO
SEE MANAGED WITH SAMUEL GAS
ELECTRIC. WE HAVE SOME MINOR
CONCERNS OF THE BILL AND WILL
BE WORKING WITH AND-
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS OFFICE. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN WE'RE
SHOWING SUPPORT FOR AB ONE SIX
FIVE SEVEN MY TO SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY EVERYONE INTERNAL
THEMSELVES FROM THE QUEUE ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE SIX FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. NOW OPEN A LINE OF
KEY. TWO ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI THE MACHETE WORK
UP ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
FOR AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WE APPRECIATE WE CAN
AMENDMENTS. TO THE LAW IS TO
MOVE FROM SUPPORT COMMENDED FOR.
THE NEXT OPEN LINE NUMBER TWO
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS KELLY BOY BUT THE
CALIFORNIA LOW CARBON. ENERGY
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESSED. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. RICHARD HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE ON THE PORCH PLEASE
CONTINUE. VERY WELL WE WILL NOW
MOVE- TWO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. WE WILL- WE DON'T
HAVE A LEAD- SPEAKER IN
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL WILL
MOVE TO THE GALLERY I DON'T SEE
ANYONE PRESENT. WHEN I MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY I DON'T SEE
ANYONE PRESIDENT WROTE THEM
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. A MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE US A PROMPT
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. MY
PLEASURE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR A. B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN YOU MAY NOW
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION OF A. B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN YOU MADE NOW PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE TO IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
OKAY WILL COME TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. IF ANYONE WISHES
TO COMMENT I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT I THINK IT IT'S AS IF
IT'S AN EXCITING. OF
POSSIBILITY IN CALIFORNIA
HAVING. A RESOURCE THAT HAS THE
LARGEST OF KNOWN GEOTHERMAL
ACTIVITY AREA IN THE COUNTRY
THE POTENTIALLY HAS PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF LITHIUM
IN OUR COUNTRY THAT WE CAN
EXTRACT THIS LITHIUM WITHIN OUR
OWN STATE FOR USE IN CREATING
THE BATTERIES SO WE'RE GONNA
PLOY IN OUR LEXICAL SYSTEM AND
THE BATTERIES OF ALL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. EVERY EVERY TIME WE
CAN PRODUCE SOMETHING IN STATE
AND CONSUME IT INSTATED HELPS
TO GROW CON ME OUR ECONOMY AND
THIS WILL ALSO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO EXPORT THIS
IMPORTANT MINERAL. TO THIS
IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
TAKING A HOLD OF THE ENTIRE
WORLD. CALIFORNIA COULD
POTENTIALLY BE A LEAD EXPORTER
OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT MINERAL.
AND I APPLAUD THE WORK. OF THE
AUTHOR IN PUTTING US ON A PATH
TO LOOK AT THIS IS A
POSSIBILITY. AND I SUPPORT THIS
ENORMOUSLY BECAUSE THERE'S JUST
SO MUCH MORE WORK THAT WE NEED
TO DO. TO HELP PUT CALIFORNIAN
A SUSTAINABLE FUTURE IN THIS
WITH THIS BILL IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT SENATOR
DODD DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
COMMENTS OF THIS GERMAN
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D LIKE TO
MOVE BILL. OKAY THEN WE WILL
MOVE THE BILL LESTER'S ANYONE
ELSE THAT WISHES TO SPEAK I
DON'T SEE ANYONE OKAY THE
SENATOR. A GREAT SENATOR. DID
YOU WANNA MAKE SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD JUST FRECKLE
THE COMMENTS THAT YOU JUST MADE
MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
LITHIUM RESERVE IN NORTH
AMERICA AND WE'RE NOT.
UTILIZING THAT. RESERVE TO
PRODUCE BATTERIES EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THOSE IN THIS.
BUILDING AND THROUGHOUT THE-
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BRIGHTEST
COUNTRY HOW THE CELL PHONE. AND
EVEN A FEW OF US HERE DR
ELECTION PARKS. IT MAKES NO
SENSE THAT THAT RESOURCES NOT.
PRODUCED A MIND HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON THAT
NOTE OURS FOR CLASS ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH THE MOTHER
IS TO PASSED PROBE. CLUB PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL BY. WITH SO I. WARLOCK.
FOR A LITTLE BIT ON. PLEASE
STATE YOUR VOTE CENTER MARLA
ABILITY NOT VOTING MOORLACH NOT
VOTING BRADFORD. HI BRADFORD BY
CHIANG. DOLLY NOT VOTING DALY
NOT VOTING. DODD HI DODD AYE
HERTZBERG. HILL HI HILL HI
MCGUIRE. RUBIO HI ON THE
MICROPHONE FROM THE TO THE
MICROPHONE CENTER RUBIO SORRY
WHEN I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RUBIO I. SKINNER BY SKINNER HI
STERN. HI SIR I WIENER HI
WIENER I. EIGHTIES VERY WELL
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT WILL HELP HOLD THE ROLE
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS. WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT BILL NOW. WE
HAVE WILL HEAR AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA HE'S READY TO GO WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS A
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO YOU
ALL ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THIS EVENING AT
THE FIRST START BY TAKING THE
CHAIR YOUR STAFF OF FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
BILL. A SENATORS AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WILL FURTHER
PROTECT ENERGY AND GAS
CONSUMPTION DATA OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO NOW MORE THAN
EVER DESERVE TO FEEL SAFE AT
HOME WHILE USING ESSENTIAL
ENERGY SERVICES PROVIDED BY OUR
UTILITIES THIS BILL REQUIRE
IMMIGRATIONS AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT TO OBTAIN A COURT
ORDER SUBPOENA OR JUDICIAL
WARRANT AS A PART OF THEIR DATA.
SAID TO UTILITIES QUESTION ANY
TIME I CAN GIVE YOU MORE
DETAILS ABOUT ALASKA. Q. OF OUR
WELL WITH ME ACTUALLY SALAS
WITH THE IT WOULD IS THE TURN
WITH THE- UTILITY REFORM AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS- YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BEGIN WITH A IS
A JEWEL ELEVEN THE IS TO SPEAK
ON. ACTUALLY SOUTH. OKAY
ACTUALLY SO. RESERVE OKAY DO WE
HAVE HER ON THE LINE. I'M SORRY
ASHLEY SO AFTERNOON SOMEONE
NUMBER GLORIA GERMAN HUESO AND
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IT'S AN HONOR TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
SALAS I HAVE BEEN A STAFF
ATTORNEY WOULD BE TOTALLY
REFORM NETWORK THE LAST FOUR
YEARS. I AM BEACON SAN DIEGO
WHERE IT'S BEEN A LIFELONG
RESIDENT. TURN ADVOCATE FOR
UTILITY CUTS FOR PROTECTION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
A PRIVATE THE ISSUE. WHEN
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES P.
JEANNIE HOW EVERYTHING AND ACT
THE GENIE STARTED ROLLING OUT
SMART METERS TO RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. KERN WHAT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
INFRINGEMENT ON CALIFORNIANS
PRIVATELY RIGHT. TURN
ADVOCATING FOR THE PC TO
REQUIRED ENERGY UTILITY
REPORTER WHO IF ANYONE WHAT'S
YOUR QUESTION THEIR CUSTOMERS
DOWN. THE TRANSPARENCY REAP
REVEAL THAT FEDERAL AGENCY
REQUEST THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS ENERGY UTILITY
CUSTOMER DATA THE POLKA WHICH
ARE REQUESTED ABOUT S. P.
GENIES CUSTOMERS. YEAH SB
JEANNIE HAS THE SMALLEST
CUSTOMER BASE ALL THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES. ONLY ONE OUT
OF EVERY SEVENTEEN I OWE YOU
CUSTOMERS. THE TRANSPARENCY
REPORT ALSO SHOWED THAT
IMMIGRATION CRAFTSMAN FORTY IN
PARTICULAR THE MAN MORE
CUSTOMER INFORMATION FROM ASK
THE GENIE FROM P. JEANNIE AND
SO HOW EVERYTHING COMBINED.
SUGGEST THE ICE IF YOU A
LOOPHOLE IN THE CURRENT LAW IN
ORDER TO TEAM CUSTOMER DATA IN
BORDER AREAS. ISSUING ITS OWN
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENAS
INSTEAD OF SECURING A JUDICIAL
WARRANT. THIS HARASSMENT CAN TO
URGE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS FROM OBTAINING UTILITY
SERVICES. CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO FEAR FOR THEIR
PRIVACY IF THEY NEED TO
ESTABLISH POTENTIALLY TELLING
SERVICES. WORK CLOSELY WITH
PARTNER THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SURE CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS
THE STATE ORACLE A RELIABLE
ENERGY SERVICES. TO PRIVATE
WITH REGARD TO THESE SERVICES.
HOW SHOULD NOT BE DISSUADED
FROM ESTABLISHING A ENERGY
SERVICES OUT OF YOUR LIFE TEAM
THE CUSTOMER DATA. THEREFORE
TURNED YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NOW
WE WILL. GO TO SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WE WILL
BEGIN. WITH A SPEAKERS HERE IN
THE GALLERY. HI TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TERM LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. ALL OTHERS MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES WE WILL GO TO THOSE
THAT WILL. GIVE US THEIR NAMES
AFFILIATION IN A POSITION ON
THE MEMBERS- ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER I DON'T SEE ANYONE
PRESIDENT. ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
STILL OUT OF MT. WILL GO TO-
THE PHONE LINES AND OUTLAST THE
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PRINT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THOSE
SPEAK WILLING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO ZERO AFTER THE TIME. WILL GO
TO LINE THREE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE INSULATION
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
OPPOSITE MARYLAND AND BREED IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER THREE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THREE
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. SCHERING MEMBER SELLING
ON THE PHONE WITH A WHITE AND
GROUP REPRESENTING NEXT
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THREE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. DANIEL AFTER THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. MY NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
HOURS ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
MAY NOW PRESS ONE ZERO THE TIME.
MR HERE WE HAVE NO ONE ON ON
PORTS FOR A. B. TWENTY THAT
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE CAN HER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL GO.
TO LEAD TO WE HAVE NO LEADS
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. SO WE WILL MOVE DIRECTLY
TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION NONE
ARE PRESENT HERE IN THE GALLERY
I SEE NINE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SO WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN SAYS FIND SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AND
A PART. IN A POSITION I'M SO
SORRY. THANK YOU SIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN SO OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASEPRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN THE SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY NOW PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION. VERY WELL
THEN WE WILL- COMPLETE A CAN
YOU ONE MORE TIME COULD YOU
PLEASE JUST A PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTERESTS
FINAL POSITION OF TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. I'D BE GLAD TO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
ONE TO IN OPPOSITION VERY WELL
WILL MOVE FORWARD. WE WILL COME
TO THE COMMITTEE NOW. AND
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE. A
WISHING TO SPEAK COMMENT OR
MAKE A MOTION I- I APPLAUD US
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIOUS WORK
ON THIS ISSUE. THIS IS A VERY
NECESSARY BILL. AND I'D LIKE TO
SEE THE BILL MOVE FORWARD
CENTER HILL I'D BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL. MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
HILL WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR- CENTER GLORIA I MEAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA. I MEAN
THERE GLORIA I CAN. MR BUT TODD
GLORIA. IT IS ALWAYS BEST TO
CHECK YES YOU WANNA MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS IT IS VERY
BRIEF INSTRUMENT THAT YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR KIND WORDS AND
FOR THE SENATORS MOTION I KNOW
HE'S A CHAMPION FOR PRIVACY
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION I SIMPLY STATED
TIME RASKIN CALIFORNIANS TO
STAY AT HOME A WE DO- NEED TO
PROTECT THEIR PRIVATE
INFORMATION FROM WARRANTLESS IN
SAYS SUBPOENA LISTS-
INTRUSIONS- THIS LETTER THIS
LEGISLATION WILL DO THAT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MOTIONED
TO PASS TO THE FLOOR CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT DO YOU HAVE
TO SENATE FLOOR. WESSEL BY.
WESSEL BY. MORLOCK NOT VOTING.
FOR LIFE NOT VOTING. BRADFORD
HI BRADFORD BY CHIANG. DOLLY
NOT VOTING SALLY NOT VOTING
DODD HI. DODD HI HERTZBERG.
HELLO HI HILL HI REQUIRE WIRE
LINE YOU MAKE A FULL. WHY I.
CAN YOU SPEAK INTO THE MIKE IS
MIKE ON. PLEASE BE CLOSER TO
THE MIKE SO CAN. WIRE AYE THERE
YOU GO HEY. MCGUIRE HI RUBIO. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER. FIVE SKINNER
AYE STERN TODAY STERN HI WIENER
HI WIENER I. NINE EIGHTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S ENOUGH TO
GET BILL OUT WILL HOLD THE OPEN
FOR OPTION MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE.
AND WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME
AND PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU READY.
WIPING DOWN THE MIKE THERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
THIS BILLS CRITICAL THE MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
AND CREATING MORE RENEWABLE
ENERGY FOR RED AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE WILL EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF BIO METHANE FROM
WASTE THAT IS CONVERTED FROM
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION. TO
CELLULOSIC WASTE LIKE DEAD
TREES AGRICULTURAL WASTE
WITHOUT THIS EXPANSION OF THE
DEFINITION WASTE LIKE DEAD
TREES OR TREE TRIMMINGS AND I
CULTURE WAY SUCH AS NOT SHELLS
WILL EITHER BE PUT INTO A
LANDFILL OR BURNED. BUT INSTEAD
THIS WHICH WILL BE CONVERTED
INTO PIPE WHEN QUALITY BILE
METHANE AND USED AS RENEWABLE
ENERGY FOR CLEANER VEHICLE FUEL
OR DURING- POWER SHUT OFF FROM
WILDFIRE SEASON. AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE WELL CALIFORNIA
PRODUCE MORE CLEAN ENERGY AND
WILL REDUCE THE HARMFUL
EMISSIONS AND I DO HAVE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT STRUCTURE.
VERY WELL WILL MOVE TO YOUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT WE- TO
JULIE ELEVEN. CORRECT JULIE
ELEVEN WITH THE BY ENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND SHE
IS SHE ON THE PHONE. YES
SENATORS GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JULIE HAVE NOTHING ON BEHALF OF
THE- ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
EIGHTY THREE ONE SIX THREE IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND CLEAN
ENERGY COAL. ESPECIALLY THE
REQUIREMENT TO REDUCE BLACK
CARBON FROM WILDFIRES IN
CONTROLLED BURNS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR NOTHING FROM LANDFILLS AND
ORGANIC WASTE SELECTED. TO THE
K. FOR THE STATE CRIME CHANGE
SCHOOL PLAN THE SHORTLY CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS REDUCTIONS. ON THE
FOURTH CARBON PLAN ALL
RECOMMEND. THE PRODUCTION AND
WE ARE WORKING. VERY BY AMERICA
ENERGY IS ALSO THE SINGLE
BIGGEST OPPORTUNITY TO GENERATE
CARBON NEGATIVE THE MISSION.
THIRTY LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
NATIONAL LAB I AM NOT
CONVERSION CAN PROVIDE TWO
THIRDS OF ALL THE CARBON
NEGATIVE ADMISSIONS NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY. AND
EXTRACTION THE COST PER TON OF
CARBON REDUCTION OF MOST OF THE
STATE OTHER CLIMATE PROGRAM.
INSTEAD OF BURNING OR LAND
TELLING THIS WAY IT CAN BE
CONVERTED TO BUY AND NOTHING. I
USED TO READ TO PROVIDE TO
REPLACE DIESEL AND HEAVY UTY
VEHICLES AND BACKUP GENERATORS.
YOU CAN BE USED TO GENERATE
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN AND TO
PROVIDE LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE ARE SO COMMITTEE TO PASS AB
THREE ONE SIX THREE. THANK YOU.
I WILL FOREVER ROBERT. BAMFORD
WITH THE NORTHERN SONOMA COUNTY
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
AS HE- MAY SAFE WHEN OUR
STUDIES ONLINE IS THE ONLINE.
YES SIR I'M READY TO GO OF THIS.
YOUR HUESO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ROBERT TO
PAMPERED AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE NORTHERN CINEMA
COUNTY- POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. OUR AIR DISTRICT
ALONG WITH MANY OTHER LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT AND CAP CO OF WHICH IS
THE ENTIRE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT. OR EIGHTY THREE ONE
SIX THREE BECAUSE WILL PROVIDE
DENTAL AIR QUALITY BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIA. BOTH WILD FIRES AND
CONTROLLED BURNS OF COURSE WAIT
AND OTHER BAD. OUR MAJOR
SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA. IN FACT A SINGLE
LARGE FIRE CAN CAUSE MILLION
THE PERSON DATE OF UNHEALTHY
AND DANGEROUS LEVELS OF AIR
POLLUTION. OPEN BURNING OF
AGRICULTURAL WEIGHT WHICH HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY ACROSS
THE STATE. IS ALSO A MAJOR
SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION. THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD
HAS FOUND THAT CONVERTING WOULD
WAIT TO ENERGY CAN CUT BLACK
CARBON METHANE AND PARTICULAR
MATTER OF MISSION BY NINETY
EIGHT PERCENT. COMPARED TO AN
OPEN BURN OF AGRICULTURAL OR
FORCED WAIT. BY ENERGY ALSO CUT
MARK FORMING POLLUTION WHICH IS
CRITICAL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
TO MEET FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. AND FINALLY
PROVIDING A BENEFICIAL
ALTERNATIVE FOR WHAT WAIT. THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO LANDFILLS
WILL HELP THE STATE MEET IT'S
WASTE DIVERSION AT METHANE
REDUCTION GOALS. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS THE NORTHERN ECONOMIC
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT AND- DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE- URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS
AB THREE ONE SIX THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS
MEANS TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MISS LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBER
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SELES A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. NO I SEE
NO ONE HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NO ONE IS PRESENT IN TWENTY
FORTY WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITED TO SATISFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
THREE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND IN FORT. THREE FIFTY SEVEN
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT WE DIDN'T
CATCH THE BEGINNING I APOLOGIZE.
TYLER TRITON ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FUND IN SUPPORT.
PLAN FOR THE REAR LINED UP IN.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS.
REITERATING OUR SUPPORT FOR A
BI THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE.
THREE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HE LEANED ON ASKING BOB
AND THEY HAVE HEALTH FORMULA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE. FOUR ZERO ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. I GET A NEW CARE
WHAT THE MEMBERS OF. THE ON
BEHALF OF. THANK. FOUR ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
KAREN MEMBERS OF THE INSULATION
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT AND THE COURT THANK
YOU. THREE NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. ON. BEHALF OF
SALT LAKE CITY NORTH AMERICA.
CORD AND RESTAURANT AFTER WE
HIS MERE IN OR YOU. THREE TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. CRITICS
IS REALLY A WHOLE BUT THE
DECISION A CALIFORNIA REGION
PEOPLE INTO COURT. TWO FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THIS IS CHAIRED SNAKE WITH SAN
JOAQUIN RENEWABLES IN SUPPORT.
FOUR ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. IT IS AN DOUBT THE PRAYER
MY CASE IN THE CASE MAY HAVE A
RECALL SURVEY IN SUPPORT. TWO
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS GOING TO LOOK
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION IN SUPPORT. FOR ALL
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THERE'S
OR SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. TWO EIGHTY YEAR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
RYAN KENNEY ON BEHALF OF THE
NATION'S LARGEST PROVIDER OF BY
A NOTHING CAN YIELD CLEAN
ENERGY IN FRONT FOR. TWO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AT
THE KELLY BOY HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOW CARBON FUEL
AND ENERGY COALITION AND ON
BEHALF OF BE GREETED ENERGY
SYSTEMS IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
ONE SIX THREE THANK YOU. AND AS
A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A BI THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE
ONE OTHER PERSON WITH AN
OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE NEXT OPEN LINE FOUR
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MEMBERS LED A FEW MINUTES AGAIN
THE TECHNICAL GAS ELECTRIC IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY THIRTY ONE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN JUST TO SHOW SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO FOUR A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WILL MOVE TO INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE WE WILL- COME TO THE
GALLERY AND NO ONE IS PRESENT
HERE IN THE GALLERY- ROOM TO
TWENTY FORTY. CAN NO ONE IS
PRESENT THERE NOW WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE AS
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WOULDN'T
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. YES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU KNOW
WHAT OPERATOR- I FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION. BUT THAT. THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AND I'M IN
A IN A ROW UP TO GOING TO THE
PUBLIC. AND OR AND- SORRY TO
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS I WILL.
WE HAVE EITHER JILL JULIA
JORDAN OR BRIAN NO WIKI
AVAILABLE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE. CARE C. YES FIND IT HERE
OKAY LET'S- HERE FROM BRIAN A
WIKI. MR WITH NO WORKING
WELCOME. DONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M BY NO WORKING THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
AND NONPROFIT ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WORKS OUT ON
CLIMATE ISSUES. SB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE. CREATE A COSTLY
PATHWAY TO MANUFACTURE MAPPING
AN EXTREMELY POTENT GREENHOUSE
GAS THIS IS NOTHING THAT WOULD
NOT OTHERWISE EXIST UNLESS IT
IS GENERATED SPECIFICALLY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SUBSIDIZED PRICING. PAID BY THE
REPAIR PROVIDED BY PROCUREMENT
TARGETS TO BE CLEAR THERMAL
CONVERSION OF BIOMASS TO
METHANE IS NOT PART OF THE
STATE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS STRATEGY. IMPACT
ANALYSES OF CONVERSION OF
BIOMASS TO MAINTAIN CONSTANT
BUT THIS PROCESS CAN ACTUALLY
INCREASE GREENHOUSE GAS
POLLUTION WHEN MATH IN THE
ACCOUNTED FOR ON TOP OF THAT
WHEN YOU BURN METHANE WHAT WE
DO IN CALIFORNIA IN OUR GAS
PLANT IN GAS POWERED APPLIANCES
YOU GET KNOCKED EMISSIONS AND
OTHER AIRPOLLUTANTS.
FURTHERMORE CONVERSION OF
BIOMASS IMAGINING IS NOT PART
OF CALIFORNIA'S DECAPITATION
ACUTE CARE A BLIND BUT A MORE
NATIONAL LAB STUDY WHICH
PROPONENTS FREQUENTLY SITE
SUPPORT FOR THE SPELL. THAT
STUDY FOCUSES ON BIOMASS
CONVERSION TO HYDROGEN NOT
MELTING HYDROGEN IS. NOT A
POLICY SHE RETAIN ITS FOCUS. ON
REDUCING OF METHANE AND GET.
NOT ENABLING NEW AND COST WAYS
TO IT AS THIRTY ONE SIXTY
PROPOSES AND FUNDS HAVE HER
THAT IS CURRENTLY BEING DIRECT.
TOWARDS HYDROGEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY OUR MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA I
REQUEST THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE THANK
YOU. VERY WELL TO WE HAVE-
JULIA JORDAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU THIS IS JULIE A
JORDAN- POLICY COORDINATOR WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROFIT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN FRESNO WE
WORK DIRECTLY WITH LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR INCLUDING. AREAS TO VAN
APPROVAL POLICY UNDER A VARIETY
OF ISSUES INCLUDING CLIMATE
AGRICULTURE LAND USE AND ENERGY.
THERE'S A COUPLE CLOSES AT
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. FOR
SIMILAR REASONS IS JUST EXPRESS
RIGHT RIGHT COLLEEN RYAN-
RATHER THAN FOCUS ON ITS
STRATEGY TO REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS IN THE STORES AND
FIND ORGANICALLY ALTERNATIVE.
CREATION OF ADEQUATE AND OTHER
USER. THIS BILL IN INCENTIVIZE
PRODUCTION OF NOTHING THE BILL
WOULD ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
FURTHER DELAY OF TRULY CLEAN
INTERMISSION ENERGY TO CLEAN UP
OUR AIR AND FUEL IT JUST FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY
THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE
METHANE EMISSIONS YOU BY
OMITTING DEVELOPMENT HAVE
LARGELY FAILED TO MEETING
COOLEY RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT
THAT THE PROBLEM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. BY LETTING
CONTINUES TO BE COUNTED AS A
BUSINESS OVER BULLET TO THE
STATE'S NOTHING PROBLEM. BUT BY
METHANE IS NOT CLEAN FUEL.
UNLIKE THEIR MISSION ENERGY IS
STILL. ALL THAT LIVE WORK AND
PLAY IN THE MOST POLLUTED AREAS
OF THE COUNTRY HERE IN
CLIFORNIA. PEOPLE THAT SUFFER
FROM DISPROPORTIONATE RATE
ASTHMA AND OTHER RESPIRATORY
CONDITIONS EXACERBATED BY POOR
AIR QUALITY. AND ADDITIONALLY
AS BRIAN NOTED METHANE LEAKAGE
IN THE HUGE ISSUE- AND WE'VE
SEEN AS WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE
IN THE PAST OF THE LISA CANYON
AND TWENTY THREE. FIFTEEN
THREE OF US YOU TO VOTE NOW ON
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY. AND PERSON
OR THAT WERE METHANE CHEN. AND
THAT IT MAY THERE ARE MISSION
POLLUTION WITH INPUT FROM CAN
ARE LET OUT OF THE COMMERCE.
AND WITH THE LAW TERM HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF RECORD IN.
CALIFORNIA AND MY- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH. YOUR
CALL NOW WILL COME BACK TO THE
TELLER FOR ORVIS. MODERATOR
PLAY PRINT AND- WERE TESTS UP.
OF AB THREE ONE SIXTY THREE.
LIKE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW THAT PRESS ONE ZERO FOR A.
B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE.
ARTICLE I NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN IN
REJECTED UNION THAT SCIENTISTS
IN OPPOSITION. THREE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LAUREN ALONG
WITH SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER CARRYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY ALSO IN OPPOSITION. FOUR
ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
JUSTICE THE CALIFORNIA TERMINAL
JACKSON ALLIANCE AND RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
THE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR A.
B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. ONCE
AGAIN A SHOW OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LEAVE KNOWING I KNOW WHEN I
SHOWING. THANK YOU OKAY WILL
COME TO THE COMMITTEE NOW TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND IF ARE NO QUESTION
OR COMMENTS EMOTION SENATOR
DOLLY. AND THEN CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A THE
I'M GONNA BE VALLEY TO MOVE THE
NUMBER ONE IT ALSO LOSE THE
BILL I KNOW THAT MY DISTRICT ON
FIRE AS MANY YOU KNOW WE HAD
OVER. A HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
SO FAR THIS MURDER THIS WILL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON BY THREE
US ACTUALLY THE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR THIS BILL WE'RE TRYING
TO FOR OUT WHAT WE'RE DO IT BY
I THINK THIS A GOODLY TO GOOD
SO I SUPPORT THE BILL. AND
HOPEFULLY CAN GET OF THESE PLAN
AND ACTUALLY STE USING THIS
TECHNO TO REDUCE OF THE WAY BY
MASS THAT SEVEN. EMITTING INTO
THAT RIGHT AND THAT'S TRUE
BLACK CARBON HURTING OTHER
PEOPLE THE BREED THAT AIR AT
LEAST IN MY JUST ALL OF THE
STATE SO THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS FOR THE FOR TO SEE THIS
TECHNO PROVE OUT. THANKS FOR
MUCH AND WE GET BACK TO YOU.
THAT M<c.cyan>. THE FIRST WILL GO</c>
TO SEE. PRESS TO DRAW A NOW.
CENTER MIKE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER IN ALL THE BRIEF. THAT
THIS IS BEEN ONE. IN VERY
GRATEFUL THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR ALL WORK ON THE AND I KNOW
THE IS IN THIS. WITH IN HIS
SISTER CENTER JUST AND THEN
ALSO THE- OF THE CO. THE END. I
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT. WITH
IN THE SHOW LIVED. POLLUTANTS
TO. IN THE FOR. CARBON PLAN. BY
A CALL FOR THE INCREASE DIAL BY
OKAY. USAGE IN PER. AT THE HERE
TODAY ON A COMMITTEE. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK THIS AS AN FOR
TO THE FLOOR. AS THIS IS A REAL.
ON THE NORTH COAST. WITH TIMBER.
AND OF THE AND AS WELL SO. THAT
WOULD BE SUPPORTING PHOTO THE
OKAY LOOK AT THE AS WE TOWARDS
OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE ANY OTHER COMMENTS. OKAY
OF A DOLLY YOU WANT TO MAKE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. WE HAVE A
MORE BY TELL DELI NOT HAVE TO
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT. I HAVE THE
WITH THE CENTER MCGUIRE ON
COMMON REGARDING THE STATE'S
AND RECOMMEND. AND PROF SERVING
AREAS HE IN THIS COMMITTEE I
I'VE COME TO KNOW THIS ISSUE
VERY WELL AND IT'S AND I ALSO
HAVE A DISTRICT THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS POLICY VERY
WELL. ONE OF THE- WORK MOST
CHALLENGED AREAS REALLY
REGARDING PARTICULAR MATTER
CONTAMINATION I REPRESENT AT IN
PRO COUNTY AND WE A KIDS
SUFFERING. FROM POOR AIR
QUALITY AND I KNOW THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM. A BAKERSFIELD STE
STATE HAS A CUT. CHALLENGE AS
WELL. MORE MORE SEQUESTRATION
THAT WE CAN BE INVOLVED IN WILL
MEAN BETTER AIR QUALITY SO IT
REALLY PAINS ME TO HEAR FROM.
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS OF
THAT OPPOSES BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT ONLY. CLEAN ENERGY ISSUE
BUT IT'S ALSO A HEALTH ISSUE
FOR VARIOUS PEOPLE WORK AND ARE
IN OUR DISTRICTS AND- AND THE
SCIENCE BACKS THIS BILL THE
SCIENCE WILL. DEMONSTRATE THAT
WE WILL REMOVE CONTAMINATION OF
PARTICULATE MATTER FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH THIS AND FOR THAT REASON I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID YOU WANT TO
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS I
THINK I'LL TAKE EACH OF THE
SENATOR'S COMMENTS AS A- AS
CLOTHES THOUGHT THAT WAS PRETTY
GOOD. AND SUMMARIZE NOT A THE
HEALTH IMPACT. BUT EVEN HOW
THIS GETS A TO MEET OR AND GOES
ESPECIALLY- AS MISTER MCGUIRE
POINTED OUT IT IS PART OF THE
PLAN ALREADY- I JUST INVITE
EACH OF THE SENATORS TO JOIN-
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
THE AIR BOARDS. RENEWABLE
ENERGY GROUP SO WASTE
MANAGEMENT GROUPS THE WATER
AGENCIES AND ALL AND-
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE. A
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE. AND THE
MOTION IS- DO PASS AS AMENDED
NO I'M SORRY. I DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE MùT IS TO
PASSAGE ABOUT. CLICK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTY ONE
THREE DO PASSED TO. WESSEL BY
WESSEL I MORE LAW HI. FOR LOTS
OF BY BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
CHIANG KAI CHIANG I DOLLY BUT-
DOLLY I. DOT HI DODD I.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG ON
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE PHIL HI
MCGUIRE HI FIRE I RUBIO HI
RUBIO. SKINNER HI SKINNER I
STERN DURING THE- STERN NOT
VOTING. WIENER NO. WIENER IN NO.
WINNER NO. ELEVEN I WHEN THOSE
CHAIR HEY. THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT OF. HOLD THE
ROLE CONTRAPTION MEMBERS
ACTUALLY THE NUMBER WAS APPS SO
THE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE BILL
WILL COME TO THE FOR BILL. AB
FIVE SEVEN TO CALL ABSENT THIS
IS EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY TO PASS
AMENDED APPROACH. CLICK PLEASE
THE UPS MEMBERS. AB FIVE SEVEN
TWO PASS AS A SUPER. MCGUIRE BY
MCGUIRE I RUBIO. FIND RUBIO
FIVE. CHAIR NINE TO THE WITH
HOLDING. VERY WELL CLOSE ROLE
ON THAT BILL AND MOVED TO THE
NEW THE MEASURE ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB EIGHT FORTY. OF THE WAS TO
PASS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE UPS
AMENDED PRIMERS AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIANG. NO
CHIANG THEM. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
SURE THAT HAS THE BILL NINE A
FOR NOW VERY WELL OF WE WILL
CALL THE ROOT OF CLOSE ROLE
THAT BILL THE BILL IS OUT THE
MOST ITEM FOR ABC. FIFTY SEVEN.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN DAY PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHIANG. KAI
SHEK FIVE HERTZBERG. FOR ONLINE
HERTZBERG I MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE
HI. THE VOTE THE BILL HAS
ELEVEN VOTES FOR WELL CLOSER
ROLE AND MOVE TO AYE NUMBER FOR
AB SO EIGHTY EIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTHER TO THE FULL. CLERK
PLEASE THE MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CHIANG
NONVOTING CANNOT VOTING. NINE A
STIR WILL LOCAL QUICKLY WITH
ROLE ON TAT BILL AND MOVE TO A
NUMBER SIX AB ONE THREE BUT
LIMóN SALAS WE HAVE ANOTHER TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATE QUIRK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT. AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE DEEPER
TWO. I'M SORRY WE'RE VERY CLOSE
ROLE ON THE ONE AFTER SO I
WE'RE WE'RE DONE FOR THE DAY SO.
I'D LIKE TO. OUT LOOK I'M SORRY
THE DOUBLE CHECK CLERK DID YOU.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY. I'M SORRY.
DID MR HERTZBERG VOTE ON. ON
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT NOW
SORRY OKAY SO TIGHTLY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT AT
THE PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
HERTZBERG LET'S FOR ALL
HERTZBERG GUY. TEN A CENTER.
OKAY SO THE BILL. IS OUT. THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUAL TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFIED TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW ADJOURNED.